[Musique]
or Stéphane bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
retrouvons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succincts
métalliques et minières et notamment la
question des impacts sanitaires et
environnement toutes ces filières comme
la dernière fois vous avez fait quoi
avant
alors avant j'ai fait un diplôme
d'ingénieur en géologie minière et avant
ça j'avais fait une prépa math physique
voilà
[Rires]
donc on vous refait venir revenir pour
la deuxième fois parce que la première
fois c'était très très bien passé
on a fait
ça a passionné notre communauté donc là
on aimerait approfondir sur deux trois
sujets on va parler plein plein de
choses nodules pollinités de transition
énergétique de disponibilité des
matériaux de concentration et tout un
tas de choses j'aimerais commencer par
vous lire un extrait d'un article de
Bloomberg qui date du 25 février 2023
qui parle de la transition énergétique
allemande qui parle du plan allemand
pour effectuer sa transition et ça dit
l'Allemagne fait face à un défi de plus
de 1000 milliards de dollars de 1000
milliards de dollars pour combler son
déficit énergétique massif et dans cet
article on parle de la transition
nécessitera l'installation de panneaux
solaires couvrant l'équivalent de 43
terrains de football et 1600 pompes à
chaleur chaque jour il a également
besoin de construire 27 centrales
éoliennes hochor et 4 offshore par
semaine selon la liste des souhaits
présentés par le
lors d'une des récentes visites au siège
de Volkswagen donc 1000 milliards en
s'étend parce que c'est pour 2030
jusqu'à 2030 est-ce que vous ça vous
paraît jouable
alors du point de vue métallique non
alors ce scénario là peut-être puisqu'on
parle d'un pays d'un programme d'implant
donc on peut pas juger effectivement de
la des capacités de l'Allemagne
puisqu'on parle de ce pays en
l'occurrence
en termes d'approvisionnement métallique
pour assurer ce programme là
effectivement c'est en tous les cas ce
type de scénario et ce type d'annonce on
les retrouve à l'échelle internationale
pas seulement effectivement en Allemagne
alors en Europe récemment peut-être que
certains d'entre vous ont entendu parler
du programme fit for fifty paré pour 55
qui est un programme européen alors qui
aujourd'hui fifty-five pardon qui en
fait est un programme européen qui est
donc dans le prolongement du Green Deal
de 2019 le pacte vert de l'Union
européenne
et effectivement il y a un certain
nombre de mesures alors le pari pour 55
à vocation d'amener à une réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 55%
en comparaison aux émissions 1990
donc c'est des
objectifs qui sont extrêmement ambitieux
et effectivement vous l'avez mentionné
c'est objectif
enfin se concrétise en l'occurrence ce
matérialise où se concentre sur le
déploiement notamment
du photovoltaïques qui est un des grands
on va dire une des grandes technologies
mises en avant dans ce type de programme
de l'éolien vous en avez parlé unchard
et offshore et puis également d'autres
technologies mais un petit peu moins en
fait on parle on pourrait parler bien
sûr des véhicules électriques voilà donc
c'est dans le prolongement logique en
tous les cas ce type d'annonce ça
effectivement pour répondre à votre
question c'est quand même très important
en termes de déploiement et en termes de
quantité de métaux nécessaires pour
alimenter ces dispositifs donc
effectivement oui c'est très important
mais c'est pas étonnant que l'Allemagne
prenne ce genre de position quand on
regarde effectivement le fameux feat for
fifty-five de l'Europe ou des américaine
ou des annonces de d'organismes tels que
par exemple l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie
ça effectivement il faut l'avoir en tête
par rapport à ces objectifs alors après
il y a plusieurs choses dans ces
programmes si on reprend si on se met
vraiment moi j'ai toujours tendance à
regarder la question plutôt du côté de
l'échelle internationale puisqu'on
notamment les filières minérales et
métalliques ce sont des filières qui
sont nécessairement mondialisées donc
c'est toujours bon quand on parle de
grands scénarios d'approvisionnement et
d'implication en terme métallique de se
positionner à une échelle internationale
dans les faits les premiers scénarios
alors il y avait des premières annonces
qui avaient été faites j'en avais
rapidement parlé la dernière fois qu'on
s'était vu donc en 2017 qui avait été
fait donc en 2017 par la Banque mondiale
et puis il y a des scénarios actualisés
qui ont été proposés par l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie laie en 2021
donc ces scénarios effectivement
explique que donc parmi les grandes
informations que l'on pourrait retenir
de cette étude bien sûr c'est une étude
très importante donc je ne vais en faire
qu'une très brève synthèse ici mais
parmi les éléments majeurs en fait
l'agence donc internationale de
l'énergie établit deux grands types de
scénarios donc on appelle les steps et
les SDS donc les steps c'est le scénario
des politiques déclarés et le SDS c'est
le scénario de développement durable
donc en fait à partir donc le scénario
de politique déclarer ça s'entend bien
c'est ce que les États et les
entreprises annoncent faire actuellement
dans l'état actuel donc en l'occurrence
en 2021 et puis vous avez le SDS qui est
le scénario de développement durable et
dans ce cadre-là vous avez en fait des
pronostics qui sont faits en termes de
déploiement d'énergie dites
renouvelables donc pas seulement
puisqu'il est aussi question de
véhicules électriques il est aussi
question de réseau électrique il est
aussi question de système de stockage
stationnaire notamment
donc batterie de stockage stationnaire
d'énergie pour être précise et donc du
coup dans ces scénarios là donc à
l'époque donc en 2021 il est notamment
fait mentions d'une augmentation donc
vous voyez on va retrouver des chiffres
qui sont qui se rapprochent de ceux que
vous venez d'évoquer on annonce une
augmentation de la puissance installée à
l'échelle internationale donc à
l'horizon 2040 j'insiste c'est 2040 pour
laieu que multiplie 3 en éolien et en
photovoltaïque donc il faut multiplier
par trois la puissance
éolienne et photovoltaïques installées à
l'horizon 2040 on est en 2021 à
l'horizon de 20 ans vous imaginez c'est
gigantesque et au mé horizon on est sur
un une multiplication de la quantité de
véhicules électriques produits que
multiplie 25
scénario de 2021 j'avais entendu dire
qu'il fallait à peu près sortir du sol
au temps de matériaux que depuis l'âge
de fer c'est ça alors exactement je peux
me permettre de péripéter donc Olivier
Vidal une publication de 2018 en 2018 en
fait il disait que la quantité totale de
métaux à produire donc lui disait pour
les 35 prochaines années donc on était
en 2018 donc ça correspond à peu près à
la même période jusqu'en 2050 serait
équivalente à la quantité totale de
métaux donc toujours un quantité cumulé
de métaux produite depuis l'Antiquité
donc c'est des ordres de grandeur qui
sont absolument gigantesques en fait
faut enfin faut s'imaginer alors bien
sûr quand on lit sur le papier que soit
un rapport de Laya ou dans une
publication scientifique de Vidal
forcément ça nous paraît pas on se dit
ça fait impressionnant en fait c'est
gigantesque en fait les taux que ça
représente en fait il faut savoir aussi
que là vous avez donné un exemple qui
est lié au plan de transition donc on a
parlé du rapport de l'iode on pourrait
aussi parler on pourra le développer si
vous le souhaitez des scénarios un peu
plus précis qui ont été faits qui sont
basés sur les scénarios de la hyac qui
ont été proposés par Grégoire Eva naker
en 2022 dans le cadre d'une étude
conjointe de Ka ou le ven et qu'a eu
leven leven et eurometo mais
indépendamment de ça déjà il faut quand
même se rappeler pourquoi enfin à quel
point c'est énorme en fait c'est
indépendamment des plantes transition
énergétiques donc si pour l'instant les
mets de côté d'accord on ne réfléchit
pas à ce que va représenter cette
demande massive qu'on vient de décrire
si on se place déjà actuellement en
termes de croissance métallique et on
essaye d'avoir un petit peu de
rétrospective donc on va dire à notre
échelle c'est à dire depuis 1950
la consommation métallique donc encore
une fois indépendamment des plantes
scénario dont tout le monde parle
actuellement les fins des plans de
transition ou des scénarios de
transition qui sont évoqués
indépendamment de cela si on regarde sur
la période 1950 donc sur une période de
70 ans et qu'on garde l'augmentation des
productions métalliques si ce texte nous
on a regardé donc les données à partir
donc de le United States géological
surveille l'uf-gs donc ils sont les
données mondiales de production les plus
connus les plus accessibles en fait vous
avez on a regardé 8 métaux on va prendre
le fer parce que souvent c'est un peu le
parent pauvre c'est loin sexy alors que
pourtant il est absolument essentiel
partout c'est le faire élastique
inférieur acier c'est à peu près un
milliard de tonnes produits de chaque
année c'est gigantesque que ça
représente bon de la chirurgie c'est un
énorme monde enfin bon c'est voilà c'est
une énorme industrie quand on regarde en
fait sur la période 1950 2020 la
quantité de fer a été multipliée par 11
par 11 la consommation énergétique pour
transformer ce fer vous le savez ou pas
alors c'est très variables puis ça va
dépendre puis ça va dépendre du type
d'acier voilà donc je veux pas donner de
chiffres que je vais vous dire des
bêtises mais en tous les cas c'est enfin
c'est très important la sidérurgie c'est
très important aussi parce que pour
faire de l'acier on a besoin certes de
minerai de ferme et on a aussi besoin de
charbon que du coup on a besoin d'asiri
que beaucoup connaissent parce qu'il y a
pas si longtemps il y en avait encore
beaucoup sur nos territoires et pas en
particulier en France et donc en
l'occurrence en fait c'est des très
grosses émetteurs de gaz à effet de
serre on le sait notamment voilà ça
c'est quelque chose qui est connu on
sait que le monde de l'acier est un dans
les toutes les filières métalliques et
minérales un des secteurs qui pèsent le
plus en termes énergétique et en termes
de d'émission gaz à effet de serre
et puis l'or c'est pareil vous êtes que
multiplie 3 à la production depuis 1950
avec un taux de croissance de mémoire de
1.9% enfin encore une fois un taux de
croissance moyen annuel bon bref donc en
fait vous êtes sur des taux qui sont
déjà gigantesques et en fait tout le
monde s'accordait déjà à dire qu'on
avait une croissance exponentielle c'est
exponentielle quand vous avez des taux
de croissance comme ça même constant à 3
4 5% à la fin ça vous fait une courbe
exponentielle qu'on était déjà si vous
voulez sur une tendance exponentielle
tendance qui est inquiétait déjà les
gens puissent qu'on connaît on en a
parlé la dernière fois qu'on s'est vu
les externalités enfin les impacts
extrêmement graves de ces filières donc
on le savait déjà si vous voulez donc ça
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
absolument pour moi avoir en tête parce
que avec une autre aussi dynamique qui
est intéressante donc et donc après on
va rajouter les plans de la transition
c'est pour ça qu'on va arriver sur des
scénarios qui sont complètement
excusez-moi du terme mais délirant c'est
à dire que en parallèle de ça du coup
donc de cette augmentation exponentielle
on s'est retrouvé en plus si vous voulez
à constater qu'on avait des effets un
peu enfants donc à partir des années
2000 notamment donc c'est hier les
années 2000 notamment avec la poussée de
technologie de l'information et de la
communication des technologies du
numérique donc on a encore poussé c'est
pour ça que par exemple vous avez des
substances on a des taux de croissance
qui sont absolument hallucinant on a
étudié par exemple le gallium on a les
chiffres de production qui à partir de
1973 pour le gallium entre 1973 et 2020
on est que multiplie de mémoire on doit
être que multiplie 20 et on a des taux
de croissance à 10.3 quoi
on est en plus des phénomènes de dopage
de dopage on a des poussées en fait déjà
sur la production donc il y a ce
scénario là et par dessus ça donc
c'était cette espèce d'état des lieux
qui est quand même extrêmement
inquiétant c'est intéressant
effectivement je voulais vous dire
quelque chose c'est que par dessus on se
rend compte que on n'a pas réussi à
faire le fameux découplage alors c'est
quoi que cette bête là le fameux
découplage en fait c'est alors il y
avait une idée il y a un principe et on
va si ce texte en fait l'association que
je représente aujourd'hui publiera un
rapport en juin prochain on ira dans le
détail sur ces questions de découplage
mais je peux déjà vous en dresser
quelques quelques faits en fait ce qui
est intéressant en gros c'est que on
comptait sur le fait de dire on va
consommer beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
métaux c'est très schématique ce que je
vous présente mais c'est vraiment pour
qu'on est un peu le principe en fait et
on va finir par bien développer un
certain nombre d'États donc les états
vont être développés puis ils vont
arriver une forme une forme de
saturation
matérielle si vous voulez et ensuite du
coup on va pouvoir revenir sur des taux
décroissants de demande métalliques
puisqu'en fait on aura on va dire comblé
en tous les cas les besoins nécessaires
en infrastructure en transport entre la
phrase structure d'énergie etc etc bon
en fait ça marche pas du tout cette
histoire là et on comptait sur un
découplage c'est à dire qu'on espérait
la croissance économique elle dépend
elle dépend intrinsèquement des
ressources des ressources et en
particulier des ressources métalliques
et on espérait qu'avec le temps un peu
dans la lignée de ce que je viens de
vous présenter on espérait qu'on
arriverait à faire de la croissance
économique donc des points de PIB et
d'avoir de moins en moins besoin de
ressources de ressources et en
particulier de matières premières
minérale donc ça c'était les grands vœux
les attentes de découplage on s'est dit
on va y arriver il faut y croire on va
arriver alors en fait
l'humanité entière là je vais quand on
dit on va y arriver c'est tout le monde
quoi c'est vraiment l'humanité entière
on va réussir
du coup c'est très inquiétant si vous
découpez pas vous faites ce qu'on fait
maintenant c'est à dire une intensité
matérielle croissante donc notamment il
y a une publication en ligne de lunettes
donc du Programme des Nations Unies pour
l'Environnement de 2020 qui vous
explique en fait en disant bah malgré
les efforts en plus de mémoire je crois
que c'est vraiment écrit comme ça malgré
les efforts qu'on a fait pour essayer
d'atteindre un découplage en fait on
observe l'inverse c'est à dire qu'on a
une intensité matérielle croissante donc
plus le temps avance plus pour créer un
point de PIB on a besoin de plus de
ressources c'est exactement qu'on aurait
souhaité et par contre c'est extrêmement
inquiétant parce que ça veut dire qu'on
a déjà une croissance métallique comme
je le présentais précédemment qui est
exponentielle depuis les années 50 et on
arrive non on n'arrive pas à faire du
découplage ça c'est clair net et précis
de toute façon on pouvait s'y attendre
voilà il y a beaucoup de chercheurs qui
le savaient qu'il n'y aurait pas de
découplage mais en tous les cas ce qui
s'est passé c'est que c'est pire ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est
d'ailleurs qu'on a de plus en plus
besoin de ressources pour la croissance
économique et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que l'Unep la même publication que celle
que je viens de vous mentionner précise
en disant on constate que la production
minière la croissance de la production
minière va plus vite que la croissance
économique en lien effectivement avec
une intensité matérielle croissante et
parallèlement si on se réfère aux
travaux de krisman et jégourel de 2020
eux ils vous disent on constate que la
production minière et la croissance de
la production de matières premières
minérale croit plus vite que la
croissance démographique
donc ça veut dire qu'en fait on est
arrivé voyez on est on est au maximum de
ce qu'on est déjà en capacité de faire
parce que on est au maximum de de ce
qu'on peut faire en termes d'intensité
matérielle sauf que ce que dit lunettes
c'est quoi c'est que ça va s'intensifier
plus le temps va avancer plus pour créer
un point de PIB si vous voulez
schématiquement un document pour créer
la croissance économique on aura besoin
de faire appel à une grande quantité de
matière première minérale et ça va être
de pire en pire donc on a déjà cette
croissance exponentielle paf on rajoute
ces tendances de d'intensité matérielle
croissante et il s'a suffisait pas oui
en 2020 on me rajoute en plus les
plantes transition alors là on est plus
sur l'exponentielle là c'est vertical
les croissances qu'il faut atteindre là
c'est plus exponentielle parce
qu'effectivement comme vous le
mentionnez à l'instant on est sur des
scénarios qui sont allez on va dire
extrêmement ambitieux
personnellement je me le permet je
trouve ça délirant les plans qui sont
aujourd'hui annoncés en matière de
métaux parce que c'est des quantités
enfin pour annoncer des quantités de
modéliser en disant on va correspondre
on va respecter les accords de Paris et
donc on va déployer je sais pas combien
d'éoliennes je sais pas combien de
panneaux photovoltaïques je sais pas
combien de véhicules électriques il y a
des réalités matérielles qui sont
énormes et on était déjà dans un
contexte contraint en fait c'est ça qui
est terrible il suffit pas juste de dire
bah écoutez c'est pas grave bon allez
transition oblige voilà il aurait déjà
fallu agir en réduisant avant même de
parler de plantes transition métallique
qui eux présentent des scénarios qui
sont complètement dentes alors pour ces
scénarios dantesques j'en tiens pour
preuve donc comme je vous l'annonçais
tout à l'heure donc une étude très
récente donc c'est Grégoire et Van
hacken de 2022 donc qui a eu les veines
et eurometo ce rapport donc qui en fait
reprend comme je vous le disais les
scénarios de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie et qui les appliques au
territoire européen en regardant ce que
ça peut donner en fonction aussi de ce
que pourrait produire l'Europe de des
besoins qu'elle a des voilà quelque
chose qui soit un peu plus spécifique au
territoire européen avec aussi une mise
en parallèle avec la demande globale
donc c'est vraiment un rapport très
intéressant très très fourni très très
documenté voilà j'incite vraiment toutes
les personnes à lire il est un peu long
un peu dur à lire mais il est vraiment
très intéressant et en l'occurrence donc
dans ce rapport il est notamment donc
ces mentions de l'application de ces
scénarios donc on nous annonce c'est
quand même fou et les gens qui écrivent
ces rapports ils vont jamais dans des
mines c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible alors il nous annonce par
exemple donc il nous explique que ils
étudient donc 11 technologies liées aux
énergies renouvelables alors ils inclut
notamment le nucléaire bon pour bien ce
qui renouvelable dans le nucléaire mais
enfin bon admettons donc on va prendre
le nucléaire et ensuite donc vous en
avez 11 alors vous en avez 11 ans vous
avez le nucléaire le photovoltaïque les
centrales solaires thermiques donc on
oublie un petit peu mais qui sont
importantes nous-mêmes des énergies
renouvelables l'éolien
le bioénergie donc les trucs avec des
plantes quoi ensuite vous avez la
bioénergie ensuite vous avez bien sûr du
coup la géothermie j'allais l'oublier
l'hydraulique évidemment les réseaux
électriques les systèmes de stockage
stationnaire les véhicules électriques
et l'hydrogène qui prennent ces 11
technologies ils regardent ils estiment
et c'est déjà super bien ce qu'ils ont
fait ils regardent la quantité de métaux
pour 29 substances alors Orphée et acier
vous inquiétez moi ça vient se passer
non donc ils freine c'est 11
technologies ils freinent le 29
substances donc encore une fois
hors-faire et acier et ça c'est
important parce que faire acier c'est
quand même voilà c'est l'assise du monde
métallique quoi vraiment il y a pas
d'acier il y a rien du tout quoi donc
bref donc voilà donc or c'est acier et
donc ils prennent les 29 substances et
il vous disent bon alors écoutez par
rapport donc si on regarde par substance
par exemple ils vous disent bah c'est
pas compliqué donc compte tenu donc il
se place dans le fameux scénario
développement durable donc pour rappel
le scénario développement durable c'est
atteindre des objectifs des accords de
Paris donc avec
réduction des émissions nettes à
l'horizon 2050 2060 pour la Chine et
2070 au plus tard pour les autres pays
mais en gros c'est à peu près ça le
scénario c'est les engagements sont
tenus les engagements des accords de
Paris sont tenus avec ce scénario là du
coup ils vous disent bah par rapport à
la demande totale de 2020 donc par
rapport à en fait la quantité de métal
qui avait été demandée en 2020 et ben on
va multiplier donc par exemple pour le
lithium que multiplie 21 en 2050
diable comment diable voulez-vous qu'en
30 ans on multiplie par 21 la production
qui était déjà très élevée compte tenu
des éléments que je viens de vous
fournir précédemment on était déjà au
taquet du lithium et donc du coup on
vous dit mais il faut multiplier par 21
il faut
il faut multiplier par 21 il faut
multiplier par 4 le cobalts de mémoire
il faut multiplier par 4 le disposium il
faut multiplier par deux nickel
alors
quand moi je assistais donc
l'association que je représente on a
bien sûr un certain nombre de contacts
dans des entreprises excusez moi je ris
j'en ai besoin de ce sinon je pleure et
du coup je vais pas pleurer devant vous
donc je vais rire à la place et donc du
coup on a des contacts dans des sites
miniers de gens qui travaillent dans des
sites ni à différents postes et quand on
leur a annonce ce genre de chiffres mais
les gens ils me disent mais on est déjà
au maximum de ce qu'on peut faire en
termes de productivité métallique sur
les sites on a des contraintes qui sont
énormes des taux de rentabilité qui sont
gigantesques vous imaginez pas que en un
claquement de doigt on va réussir en
fait à produire quatre cinq fois plus
enfin c'est voilà c'est extrêmement
compliqué si vous voulez
mettre des petits enfants travaillant
dans les mines avec des abonnés Shetland
a été développé pour ça le poney de mine
j'entends bien
ça va être compliqué la mine actuelle
elle va avoir du mal à fonctionner avec
des poneys il faut des gros gros poneys
avec du plutôt 3000 chevaux faits
[Rires]
en trottinette électrique voilà mais
donc tout ça pour dire effectivement que
voilà donc les scénarios voilà comme je
vous disais c'est que multiplie 21 donc
c'est complètement pas accessible j'ai
lu une étude de 2022 donc du cabinet PwC
pour ceux qui connaissent qui
effectivement alerté en disant attention
on n'est pas en capacité aujourd'hui
enfin ça va être difficile quoi c'est
faisable mais ça va être difficile puis
ça demande des investissements
gigantesques il y a aussi des questions
aussi de durée de mise en exploitation
on met pas un site en exploitation comme
ça c'est des mécanismes qui sont assez
longs entre le moment où vous découvrez
le gisement vous explorez vous afin de
reconnaître on va dire le
comment dirais-je le allez on va dire
Lama minéralisée quelle taille fait
plutôt
très avec une minéralisation qui est
très très dispersée souvent donc
effectivement le temps que vous
reconnaissiez ça que vous fassiez
éventuellement les études voilà après
vous avez un certain nombre d'études à
mener donc notamment celles qui sont
assez connues souvent dont on entend
parler ses études de préfet de
faisabilité qui sont notamment remises
aux investisseurs ou sur les bourses sur
les espaces boursiers pour essayer un
peu de décrire le projet son intérêt
pour lever des fonds bien sûr une fois
que toute cette étape d'exploration est
terminée il faut ensuite rentrer dans la
phase d'exploitation donc obtenir les
autorisations ça peut être plus ou moins
long et ce sera de plus en plus long
plus que plus le temps va avancer plus
les états vont être vigilants quant à la
conduit des activités du point de vue
environnemental social sanitaire ou pas
alors
voilà ça c'est un sujet qu'on pourra
effectivement évoquer sur la question de
la réglementation mais en tous les cas
il est en tous les cas il est attendu
que ce soit de plus en plus long
notamment en termes de réglementation en
tous les cas ce serait légitime quoi
qu'il en soit ce serait légitime que ce
soit le cas donc effectivement avec le
temps on va se retrouver avec donc une
augmentation en plus de ces durées
d'instruction au sens large et puis
après il faut le mettre en exploitation
avant de démarrer l'exploitation en tant
que tel vous avez une phase de
construction qui peut être plus ou moins
longue vous dans lequel il faut que vous
installiez vous bases vie que vous
installiez d'avoir les infrastructures
nécessaires la dernière fois avec vous
on a parlé du projet montagne d'or qui
se retrouvait en forêt donc amazonienne
en Guyane française typiquement vous
aviez déjà une anoménagement de route
sur 120 km pour accéder au site minier
ensuite il fallait amener l'électricité
jusqu'au site minier donc du coup en
plus ça nécessitait d'évaluer la
possibilité d'installation portuaire
ainsi que d'installation de production
énergétique il y avait même envisagé des
centrales à partir d'hydrocarbures
fossiles pour fournir l'électricité pour
la trimballer sur 120 km pour que ça
aille jusqu'au site minier donc toutes
ces infrastructures doivent être mises
en place et c'est bien après que vous
allez pouvoir démarrer l'exploitation
alors il est connu que les temps de mise
en service d'une mine 10 minutes avec le
temps c'est une réalité mais le fait est
que bon pour moi un ordre de grandeur
raisonnable serait à peu près une
quinzaine d'années quoi entre le moment
où vous commencez l'exploration du
gisement et puis le moment où vous
démarrez l'exploitation je suis pas
analyste minière donc je suis pas une
spécialiste mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est des ordres de grandeur que je lis
régulièrement à peu près une quinzaine
d'années donc effectivement il y a des
gens qui vous disent ça va être très
très compliqué de produire ces constater
là quand vous imaginez il faut 21 pour
le lithium x 4 pour le cobalt fois 4
pour l'isrosium quoi deux pour le nickel
il y en a et c'est des chiffres plus
petits mais c'est déjà énorme c'est déjà
des quantités énormes et effectivement
ce qui est intéressant donc il vous
disent donc encore une fois par rapport
aux deux scénarios le scénario très très
optimiste et plus le scénario des
politiques déclarées le même donc de
Grégoire et Van hacken vous explique que
en fait ça représenterait en fait entre
jusqu'à 2050 ça représenterait un
doublement de la production métallique
donc sur le scénario développement
durable donc le plus haut ça
représenterait un surplus pour la
transition énergétique de 80 millions de
tonnes et pour le scénario des
politiques déclarés un peu plus bas
c'est un petit peu moins ambitieux on va
dire ça représenterait de mémoire 45
millions de tonnes je sais plus c'est 35
ou 45 millions de tonnes en tous les cas
si tous les cas sur le scénario à 80
millions de tonnes on voit très bien en
fait à quelle part contribue chacune des
fameuses onces technologies dont je vous
parlais et donc sur ces 80 millions de
tonnes donc nécessaires à l'horizon 2050
pour assurer la demande de la transition
énergétique à l'échelle globale donc à
l'échelle mondiale
et bien sûr c'est 80 millions de tonnes
vous avez 50 à 60%
on arrête les véhicules thermiques en
2035 a dit Madame Vander
voilà 50 à 60 % donc de cette demande
pour la transition énergétique à
l'horizon 2050 soit 50 à 60 %, c'est les
véhicules électriques uniquement les
véhicules sur les 11 ensuite vous avez
35 à 45% c'est les réseaux électriques
et
le photovoltaïque donc ça ne comprend
pas les centrales thermiques solaires et
vous allez me dire là vous en avez
évoqué que trois donc il m'en reste 8 et
bien les 8 c'est les 5%
donc du coup c'est en fait ce qui est
hyper important d'avoir en tête pour moi
là-dedans c'est de dire mais en fait
quand bien même on aurait une énergie à
foison disponible quand bien même il y
avait pas d'impact de la mine
effectivement déjà ces scénarios sont
extrêmement ambitieux ne serait-ce que
le sur la faisabilité technique de
produire la quantité de matière première
minérale nécessaire à ces scénario là où
en fait on a une obligation morale
d'alerter sur les conséquences de ces
scénarios c'est les implications
sanitaires environnementales humaines
sociales les bouleversements majeurs
aujourd'hui on le sait si textes la
démontré dans un rapport en novembre
2021 en long en large et en travers que
on il y avait actuellement il y avait
des impacts majeurs on n'était pas du
tout en maîtrise on n'est pas en
maîtrise de la plupart des impacts sur
les très très gros sites d'exploitation
et là en fait ce qu'on envisage c'est de
faire 20 fois plus même même trois fois
plus mais on arrive déjà pas à maîtriser
actuellement et vous faites ça x 3 donc
c'est normal que ça pose problème
ouvrez la parenthèse
[Rires]
ça va apporter le progrès c'est ça va
aider les gens on va rouler en
électrique on aura plus de CO2 dans
l'air et ça va aider le développement
économique de notre société on va faire
notre mue de grosses chenilles sales qui
consomment un beau petit papillon parce
que quand je vous entends avec les
scénars et quand je lis les scénarios de
nos politiques c'est motivé par ce
progrès ce côté vert pur le côté un peu
greenwashing on va passer tout au
renouvelable
le côté vert vu ce que je vous ai dit il
tombe il tombe à l'eau direct d'ailleurs
à ce titre là je pourrais vous renvoyer
justement sur le côté vert etc
je pourrais vous renvoyer vers une
publication de Hunter et tal de 2020
donc qui est mentionné justement dans le
rapport de system de novembre 2021
donc en fait c'est une publication qui
regarde je vous en parle parce que du
coup on va parler de la question verte
notamment
en fait donc c'est chercheurs ont
regardé
l'emprise des sites miniers
anciens en cours d'activités et à venir
donc en phase d'exploration
qui les CD scories partout et on pouvait
les tracer ou on parle ancien quelle
année alors je reviens après sur Zenter
et j'ouvre la parenthèse sur les anciens
sites les anciens sites milliers il y en
a plusieurs millions dans le monde
on estime que la plupart alors bien sûr
il y en a qui date de l'époque romaine
on en connaît en Europe on en a un
certain nombre qui pose d'ailleurs de
graves problématiques sanitaires et
environnementales
à l'échelle internationale donc comme je
vous disais on estime qu'il y a
plusieurs millions de sites miniers
abandonnés pour une période qui
probablement fait en termes de quantité
de déchets on va dire bien sûr qu'il y a
pas d'études détaillées sur tous les
sites on n'a pas de nombres précis mais
on sait que globalement c'est cohérent
enfin le développement de
et cohérent avec le développement de
l'activité minière donc plutôt au moment
de la révolution industrielle donc on a
plutôt un développement à partir de 18
50 globalement à la louche et c'est vrai
que du coup plus le temps va avancer
plus l'activité minière va être rendue
difficile donc de fait plus la quantité
déchets et la quantité de problématique
de fait va augmenter ça c'est un fait
donc oui quand on parle de d'anciens
sites miniers on parle plutôt de ses 150
dernières années et effectivement ces
sites posent une quantité de problèmes
incroyable qui sont alors eux qui
passent complètement sous les radars
complètement sous les radins
c'est-à-dire que la mine est terminée
terminée donc ça veut dire que on ne
s'occupe plus de savoir ce qui se passe
alors j'en parle en disant madame
Stéphan elle exagère ah mais non mais
elle exagère pas du tout madame Stefan
madame Stéphan elle peut vous dire qu'on
estime autour de 1% le site minier dans
le monde qui ont été réhabilités vous
inquiétez pas je vais pas oublier votre
question sur zone interétal et sur les
propres et le progrès promis mais je
reviendrai après mais je je pousse la
parenthèse sur les anciens sites miniers
en fait il y a peut-être on va dire 1%
je veux dire en Afrique du Sud Dieu sait
que c'est un pays qui a connu une
activité milliard démentielle et qui
connaît toujours une activité milliard
démentielle de fait on est à 0,6% des
sites réhabiliter aujourd'hui sur le
territoire
de mémoire c'est le Parlement c'est le
Parlement c'est un document de travail
du Parlement de d'Afrique du Sud qui
avait été remis d'ailleurs je pourrais
enfin l'appareil la source je l'ai je
l'ai en tête mais je suis quasi sûr que
c'est la source du Parlement voilà c'est
06 pour cent qui ont été réhabiliter et
encore réhabiliter
s'il y avait les dix commandements de
cystex il y en aurait un qui dirait on
ne dépollue pas un site minier il y a
jamais de retour à l'état initial sur un
ancien site minier c'est de la perte
définitive
c'est définitif c'est à dire que au
mieux ce que vous pouvez faire c'est
mettre en place un certain nombre de
mesures pour restaurer c'est à dire par
exemple confiner les déchets les plus
dangereux
éventuellement réhabiliter c'est à dire
restaurer un petit peu terrasser
restaurer des cours d'eau ou des zones
voilà ça vous allez pouvoir le faire ça
c'est faisable c'est ce qu'on appelle la
réhabilitation mais j'en tiens pour
preuve une publication excellente de
Bretéché et poney de 2013 sur les
filières enfin sur l'uranium en France
elle vous explique en fait elle vous dit
mais en fait c'est une procédure
d'invisibilisation plus qu'une procédure
de réhabilitation c'est de
l'invisibilisation c'est-à-dire
on remplit les mines à ciel ouvert on
les remplit pas nous avec des sauts
c'est qu'en fait bon bah du coup une
fois qu'on a fini l'exploitation l'eau
revient à son équilibre naturel son
équilibre hydrostatique donc elle
revient voilà donc on se retrouve avec
des grandes piscines on en fait des jeux
voilà ça fait de l'économie l'économie
du tourisme donc voilà on va en faire
avec des gens qui font du pays
les clubs de plongée vous en avez j'ai
des exemples extrêmement précis de club
de plongée dans des anciennes ouverts
françaises
en Belgique mais en tous les cas voilà
vous avez donc toutes ces problématiques
là
où on va essayer en fait de faire au
mieux en gros pour limiter au maximum
les impacts graves c'est-à-dire que
c'est ça l'objectif d'une réhabilitation
en toute priorité le fait qu'il y ait
des terrains qui restent pollués le fait
que vous ayez des cours d'eau qui soit
pollués de façon pérenne quand on dit
pérenne on parle plutôt de centaines ou
de milliers d'années pour mémoire le
métal ne se dégrade pas donc il change
de forme mais il va pas se dégrader les
pollutions minières elles sont pérennes
sur des cycles de centaines à des
milliers d'années des milliers d'années
je me souviens d'une publication de
mémoire c'est burnettal 2015 qui suite
donc il y a une grosse rupture de digue
minière donc avec une grosse coulée de
bout au Canada en 2014 ça a été
catastrophique en Colombie-Britannique
c'est le site de mantoley pour ceux qui
veulent voir les photos c'est affligent
donc c'est une grosse rupture de Dick
qui a eu lieu au Canada en 2014 le l'un
des groupes en fait il y a un certain
nombre de chercheurs et de groupes qui
ont travaillé dessus et de mémoire
burnétale parler de plusieurs milliers
d'années avant que la contamination des
zones qui ont été sous-influence de
cette déversement de résidus suite à
cette coulée de boue puisse revenir à un
état à peu près stable quoi à peu près
normal quoi ça arrive avec quelle
fréquence ce type d'accident alors les
ruptures de digue minière c'est rare
dans la tête des gens enfin on va dire
des surtout des gens qui qui sont qui se
trouvent loin en fait pas des sites
miniers
par exemple pas du tout dans la presse
alors en moyenne c'est 4 à 7 ruptures de
digue minière par an
ium project passe de données
chronologique
c'est un site internet
ça va aller vous inquiétez pas donc
effectivement c'est le wiseranium
Project lui-même en fait alors on estime
il n'y a pas que le whyuranium Project
mais l'avantage c'est que c'est une base
de données publiques qu'elle est
facilement accessible et que elle elle
référence les ruptures de digue minière
majeures donc ça c'est important on
estime que historiquement alors bien sûr
un historiquement n'a pas toujours
référencé les ruptures de digue minia et
plus le temps avance bien sûr plus on
les documents donc il y a forcément un
biais dans l'accès à la donnée puisque
plus le temps avance plus on a accès à
de l'information en tous les cas
actuellement on estime qu'il y a à peu
près 200 ruptures de digue importante
qui ont eu lieu dans le monde
donc sur les allées à la louche depuis
1900 je vous le dis vraiment la louche
parce qu'il y en a qui sont hantés 1900
mais globalement le gros c'est à partir
du en 1900 c'est à partir de là on
commence le référencement donc il y a à
peu près voilà ça et vous avez notamment
des auteurs qui sont très connus une
magnifique publication booker et
Chambers de 2015 notamment qui en fait
référence
un certain nombre de très nombreuses
ruptures de digue et qui en fait regarde
l'évolution dans le temps justement en
terme de gravité en terme de moteur etc
donc elle vous elle vous décrivent cette
publication elle décrit extrêmement bien
l'évolution des ruptures de digminiens
donc il vient en complément de cette
base de données publiques que j'évoquais
et typiquement donc booker et Chambers
et enfin mettre des espèces de niveau de
gravité si on peut se le permettre alors
c'est très délicat on s'entend sur une
rupture de digue minière donc ils
expliquent par exemple que pour eux une
rupture de digue très sévère c'est une
rupture de digue donc on s'entend une
rupture dix c'est une défaillance sur
l'ouvrage de confinement qui stocke les
résidus minier c'est une grande bassine
schématiquement et vous avez en fait une
une
une défaillance voilà il faut le dire
comme tel c'est une défaillance de
l'ouvrage de retenue derrière lesquels
se situe les résidus miniers donc en
fonction de la taille et de type de
défaillance vous allez avoir vous pouvez
aller jusqu'à une vague debout qui va
tout détruire sur son passage quoi enfin
c'est incroyable la rupture de digue de
brumadinho en janvier 2019 qui s'est
déroulée donc dans le minage RS la
région du Mina GERES mine de fer de
brumadignon au moment où la coulée de
bouée est partie enfin la vitesse dans
les premiers kilomètres c'était 110 km/h
quoi vous imaginez
110 km/h donc c'est vraiment très
c'est vraiment destructeur en fait et
cette fameuse rupture de digue elle a
quand même conduit au décès de 272
personnes
la coulée debout s'est étendue sur plus
de 300 km
donc le fait est indépendamment de cela
donc pour en revenir effectivement à la
sévérité donc bunker et Chambers en fait
disent le 13 sévère les ruptures de
digue les plus sévères il les quantifie
ainsi il les décrivent ainsi les
critères c'est il faut qu'il y ait plus
à peu près une vingtaine ou plus de gens
qui sont décédés ou autre critère
possible il faut qu'il y ait plus de 1
million de mètres cubes de matériaux qui
se soit échappé qui se soit on va dire
déversé dans l'environnement ou autre
critères possibles il faut que la coulée
de bout elle est parcourue au moins 20
km voilà des très sévères sur les 200
que je vous mentionné précédemment on
estime à peu près une centaine
c'est pas beaucoup par rapport aux
progression
ça vous donne quand même un ordre de
grandeur de de
ces catastrophes septembre 11 septembre
c'est le 11 septembre de mémoire 12
septembre bon septembre 2022 Jagger
fonstane désolé pour la prononciation
Afrique du Sud mine de diamant
5 millions de mètres cubes qui sont
partis septembre 2022 c'était hier 5
millions de mètres cubes de villages qui
ont été tout ou partie détruit six
personnes mortes ou portées disparu
ça c'était en septembre
non non non
c'est un des
mécanismes je veux dire celle de
brumadignon elle a tellement fait de
bruit que oui ah oui oui il y a eu des
indemnisations mais
40 euros
je sais qu'il y a eu des indemnisations
mais je sais pas en plus c'était
vachement compliqué parce que quand
brume adini a eu lieu en fait ça en fait
ça a contaminé donc sur 300 km tous les
cours d'eau enfin le cours d'eau majeur
qui a été traversé du coup il y a eu des
problèmes d'accès aux terres des
problèmes d'accès à l'eau potable donc
il a fallu en plus assurer des
programmes de mise à disposition d'eau
potable pour les populations enfin il y
a des milliers de personnes qui du jour
au lendemain se sont retrouvés sans eau
potable sans électricité enfin c'était
l'enfer c'était l'enfer sans compter le
fait que on cherchait désespérément les
corps de gens comme je disais à 272
personnes parce que la digue minière qui
a rompu se trouvait en amont et
topographiquement au-dessus
des bâtiments de la mine où se
trouvaient les ateliers la cantine etc
quand la rupture de digue a eu lieu en
fait elle a entraîné tous les bâtiments
il y avait donc c'est principalement des
mineurs en fait qui étaient au travail
qui était dans la cantine dans les
bureaux et donc tous les bâtiments ont
été emportés on compte pas les centaines
et centaines d'animaux qui sont morts la
contamination étendue voilà c'est une
des plus grandes catastrophes qui a eu
lieu au Brésil elle se déroulait 4 ans
après une autre rupture du même type en
novembre 2015 pour mémoire qui était la
rupture de digue de dans la mine de
Mariana aussi mine de fer toujours dans
l'état d'images grs au Brésil là je vous
ai parlé de Jager soundstein en
septembre 2022 en novembre 2022 rebelote
allez hop la mine de Williamson mine de
diamant aussi tiens voilà mine de
diamant mine de Williamson en Tanzanie
enfin voilà ça ça ne cesse pas en fait
ces ruptures de digue donc bref je ferme
la parenthèse effectivement sur la
question des ruptures de Dick c'est pas
du tout un phénomène
qui est rare mais par contre ce qu'il
faut avoir en tête c'est
qu'effectivement comme vous le soulignez
c'est quelque chose qui est très très
peu médiatisé alors que c'est des
catastrophes humaines et
environnementales gravissime on part on
parle pas d'un petit accident on aurait
le puym de ça sur notre territoire on
serait extrêmement émus et désespéré je
veux dire on s'aimait beaucoup moins de
la réalité et sachant qu'on parle pas
nécessairement encore une fois pas
uniquement de la Tanzanie je vous
donnais l'Afrique du Sud et la Tanzanie
je vous parle du Brésil je peux vous
parler du Canada je vais vous parler de
la Roumanie je peux vous parler de la
Hongrie voilà nous en mai dernier
assistex on est allé voir une zone qui
était en Espagne donc voilà on en a
partout des ruptures je peux vous parler
de la Finlande si vous voulez pareil
devant 2012 allons-y si vous voulez des
pays qui sont dirige ou développés parce
que du coup on a l'impression que ça
mais non ça se passe pas
moi je sais plus comment on dit alors
comme j'ai pas envie de dire de bêtises
je vais dire pays non mais je vous en
prie mais du coup j'ai toujours peur
avec cette histoire de pays développés à
partir de quand on considère qu'un pays
est développé du coup je préfère dire
paix d'y développer si ça vous va voilà
des pays d'idées ils ont appelé des
problèmes donc je ferme la parenthèse
sur la question des ruptures de digue
mais en tous les cas effectivement pour
en revenir à cette question des des
anciens sites miniers en fait c'est une
question qui est absolument cruciale
mais qui est vraiment crucial
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait elle porte en
son sein cette question la viabilité du
projet minier c'est à dire que
effectivement si on vous laisse enfin si
on considère que vous êtes responsable
des pollutions sur des milliers d'années
pollutions que vous avez générées dans
le cadre de votre activité industrielle
de fait c'est pas la même que si on vous
autorise à vous débarrasser de vos
responsabilités et de les donner
je comprends pas bien vous autorise
bon on peut prendre le cap du droit
français mais c'est pareil partout quand
vous avez fini une exploitation minière
on a fait le trou trou on a fait passer
les poneys
on a fait un terrain d'enfant un terrain
de jeu de ok vous avez des problèmes
alors ça c'est dans le meilleur des cas
si vous avez fait un terrain un enfant
la plupart des sites sont pas
réhabiliter ils sont abandonnés
c'est-à-dire qu'une fois que vous avez
utilisé vos poneys et tout ça vous
prenez les clés vous fermez la porte et
vous vous en avez
une petite pancarte quand même
non ah bah oui on les sécurisé quand
même
parfois oui en tous les cas au moins sur
alors bien sûr ça dépend vous avez des
territoires par exemple en Espagne il y
a très peu de mise en sécurité qui est
faite notamment au niveau des ouvrages
souterrains donc bon du coup
effectivement dans ce cadre là vous
allez avoir des problématiques de
sécurité potentielle en France par
contre c'est assez strict au niveau des
ouvrages des bouchons jour ce qu'on
appelle les ouvrages des bouchons jour
c'est-à-dire les accès au niveau des
travaux miniers souterrains là c'est
plutôt strict effectivement en général
c'est fermé ça c'est uniquement pour les
aspects miniers de mines assiettes
ouverts ou de travaux miniers
souterrains d'accès au niveau des
travaux miniers sous terre mais au-delà
de ça effectivement la plupart du temps
les dépôts de déchets miniers peuvent
être laissés en l'état les les
installations de traitement
leur mets peut-être un petit capuchon
pour éviter que ça s'envolo 80
on vous amène vous allez voir il y en a
plein des dépôts je sais pas allez on va
aller voir où en France
et ben allez à côté de Figeac il y a des
grands tas de sable blanc là c'est pas
dit ça bah c'est pas du sable c'est des
gros dépôts de résidus minier qui datent
des années de mémoire 70 min de
plonzingue de Plagnol vous allez je sais
pas moi celle-ci les milliers et les
milliers ou les millions de résidus
miniers de tonnes de résidus minier qui
se situe à celle-ci donc dans l'eau de
l'ancienne mine d'or de celle-ci
le fait est que la plupart des sites
quand même donc en France la plupart des
sites ont été abandonnés souvent
les déchets dans le domaine métallique
le charbon c'est à part charbon uranium
c'est à part je vous parle des mines
métalliques donc or cuivre plomb etc
pas connaissance de mine de lithium mais
il doit bien y avoir quelques petits
projets de lithium par là pas
connaissance de 20 tous les cas c'est
quoi j'ai pas de site à vous donner là
en tête voilà il y a peut-être eu de la
récupération de lithium pourquoi pas oui
enfin bon donc vous avez plusieurs
centaines de sites donc on va dire de
substances métalliques entre guillemets
en tout cas j'exclus pour l'instant le
charbon et l'uranium qui ont
effectivement eux étaient pris en charge
de façon importante ainsi que les
potasses donc voilà pour le potassium
voilà ça c'est ça c'est en fait donc je
ne prends que les mines métalliques sur
les mines métalliques il y a énormément
de sites sur lesquels en fait on est
simplement on est parti en fait même
quand on faisait quelques travaux de
réhabilitation le parent pauvre en
général c'était les dépôts de déchets
miniers qu'on a laissé ou les aquifères
miniers c'est à dire en fait les os qui
se sont chargées au contact des faciles
minéralisés lorsqu'on a fini les travaux
d'exploitation que les eaux remontent
dans les galeries que les horreurs
montent dans les mines souterraines et
que du coup on se retrouve avec des eaux
chargées parfois très contaminées tout
ça ça a été abandonné et le fait est en
fait c'est que aujourd'hui en l'absence
donc quand l'exploitant a quitté il a
fait un certain nombre de travaux je
pourrais rentrer bien sûr dans le détail
de toutes les procédures actuelles mais
ce serait un petit peu barbant mais en
tous les cas je schématiquement ce qu'il
faut que vous en reteniez c'est qu'il a
présenté un programme de travaux de
réhabilitation ou de travaux de
fermeture auprès de l'État et que c'est
encore une fois tous ces schématique
l'État en fait finalement à la lecture
de ces documents nonobstant
éventuellement quelques petites demandes
de modification à la fin va donner
quitus à l'exploitant pour quitter donc
ce qu'on appelle un acte en français en
froid dans le droit français ce qu'on
appelle la renonciation c'est à dire
qu'en fait du coup vous avez concédé un
droit à un exploitant pour qu'il ait
accès au sous-sol du coup à la fin de
l'exploitation on rentre dans une
démarche de renonciation on renonce au
droit qui nous a été concédé sur le
sous-sol français qui pour mémoire
sous-sol est toujours propriété de
l'État le sol et le sous-sol le sous-sol
vous pouvez avoir des propriétés privées
le sol c'est propriétaire le sous-sol ce
sera toujours le propriétaire sera
toujours l'état fermons la parenthèse
donc
du coup à la fin au moment où vous
faites cet acte de renonciation comment
vous partez du site minier de fait vous
avez donc un peu inquiétus en fait enfin
c'est ce qu'on appelle un quitus c'est à
dire que voilà donc vous allez avoir
possiblement ce qu'on appelle la police
des mines qui peut durer c'est on peut
avoir des phénomènes des mécanismes de
surveillance de contrôle parfois même
les exploitants peuvent être incités à
financer sur le long terme certains
travaux de suivi des installations de
traitement des eaux par exemple mais en
l'occurrence globalement c'est pas le
cas alors en France c'est déjà vraiment
pas bon du tout à l'international mais
c'est la catastrophe c'est la
catastrophe il y a plusieurs centaines
de milliers de sites miniers abandonnés
aux États-Unis sans aucune forme de
procès et je parle pas de l'Australie je
crois qu'ils étaient à 50 ou 80 000
enfin c'est c'est une accumulation
d'anciens sites pour lesquels personne
n'a rien fait qui reviennent donc à leur
responsabilité de qui des kangourous et
des kangourous exactement du
contribuable
c'est le gogo voilà c'est le
contribuable qui paie alors c'est le
contribuable qui peut en France c'est le
contribuable qui peut à l'étranger pour
le coup il y a pas de distinction là
alors ça c'est une réalité qui est très
très importante à avoir en tête parce
que ça veut dire que si on intègre cette
gestion post-activité ça peut tout
changer ça peut tout changer
financièrement parlant alors bien sûr on
a toujours du mal à évaluer bien sûr les
coûts c'est à dire que d'autant qu'en
général les coûts de réhabilitation sont
systématiquement sous-estimés c'est
vraiment c'est systématique donc alors
de plus en plus les états essaient de
mettre en place qu'on appelle des
garanties financières qui peuvent
prendre différents formats en fonction
des États aux différentes formes pardon
en fonction des États concernés
l'objectif étant de mettre un peu de
côté sur un compte de l'argent en cas de
pépin c'est si l'exploitant fait
faillite ou si il est en difficulté
financière l'objectif est de pouvoir
aller chercher cet argent
pour en fait mener des travaux de
réparation ou de restauration ou de mise
en sécurité voilà il faut essayer de
voir ce qui est possible en fait donc ça
ça existe il y a des publications
canadiennes qu'on a étudié parce que
dans le cas du rapport que je vous
parlais tout à l'heure dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure de novembre 2021
si c'est que ça consacré un chapitre à
la situation des anciens sites miniers
dans le monde et effectivement il y a un
certain nombre de publications
canadiennes notamment j'ai le souvenir
je crois que c'est Clippers 2003 de
mémoire à un moment qui en fait vous
explique comment en fait c'est la guerre
pour avoir des garanties financières qui
soient à l'image de ce qu'on pourrait
espérer en fait c'est la guerre entre
les exploitants et et les commandes les
gouvernements pour essayer de se mettre
d'accord sur une enveloppe qui
conviendrait à tous voilà donc la
question des anciens cycliers c'est
extrêmement problématique ça représente
des milliards et des milliards de
dollars par an qui sont investis par les
États pour compenser ou pour gérer ces
sites en tous les cas les sites les plus
graves quoi on parle des sites les plus
graves parce que bien sûr que les États
ne sont absolument pas en
mesure d'intervenir financièrement pour
la restauration de tous ces sites c'est
impossible financièrement c'est pas
possible de toute façon donc ces anciens
sites miniers sont à prendre en compte
parce que effectivement on a encore une
vue très étroite on considère que le
projet minier démarre au moment où on
extrait la première tonne de minerai et
au moment où on met la clé sous la porte
c'est absolument pas le cas le projet
mini le démarre très en amont quand on
fait l'exploration et l'étude du
territoire quel est ce territoire
comment je peux m'inscrire dedans
comment ça va se passer quelles sont les
perturbations quelles sont les
infrastructures qu'elles contexte
géopolitiques jusqu'à la fin de
l'activité minière et bien bien bien
bien après l'activité minière et ça en
général bon c'est très sous-estimé en
fait alors les gens disent oui on essaye
de plus en plus d'avoir des plans de
réhabilitation qui soit qui intègre de
plus en plus c'est considérations
ils prennent de l'électricité verte ils
ont des des machines qui polluent moins
ils utilisent moins d'acide ils font
moins de rejet aidez-moi là il faut les
défendre un peu quand même parce que
vous assurer une transition écologique
et énergétique
c'est mal barré
donc effectivement la question de
l'après mine j'aimerais que ce soit pris
en fin que ce soit bien en tête enfin
que les gens le maximum de gens les en
tête donc même en système c'est un
travail actuellement sur une grosse
étude en France métropolitaine sur
l'état des lieux des pollutions minières
sur le territoire métropolitain l'étude
devrait être publiée peut-être l'année
prochaine on espère où vous vous rendez
compte je reviens sur votre question sur
l'amélioration des pratiques minières
mais en l'occurrence en fait je vous en
parle parce que
il y a des réalités humaines qui sont
dramatiques en fait derrière on parle de
famille qui sont laissées pour compte si
ce texte en a rencontré un certain
nombre on est loin d'avoir rencontré
toutes les familles qui sont en détresse
aujourd'hui en France dans notre pays
c'est nos voisins c'est nos concitoyens
on a un minimum à faire de respect et
d'appui et de soutien auprès de ses
familles là et aujourd'hui forcer de
constater que l'État est complètement je
dirais
l'État français en fait en l'occurrence
se décharge de toute responsabilité
alors il profite de vie de lacunaire
dans les on pourrait largement entrer
dans le détail des vies de lacunaire
permis par le droit français en matière
de gestion des anciens sites miniers
mais en fait il profite de vie de
lacunaire de vie de lacunaire de ville
juridique
avis de lacunaire c'est quand même
sacrément vide qui du coup en fait
lui permet de se décharger de
responsabilité et ça laisse des familles
des communes dans des situations qui
sont dramatiques parce que dès qu'on est
informé de ces pollutions minières on se
retrouve alors du point de vue des
communes avec des zones qui sont
contaminées dont on ne sait que faire
donc pour lesquels on ne sait pas
comment intervenir et pour lesquelles on
n'a pas forcément les moyens financiers
surtout quand on est une petite commune
pour pouvoir intervenir pour la mise en
sécurité de ces zones et s'agissant des
familles enfin il y a énormément de
familles qui ont découvert du jour au
lendemain qu'on leur avait vendu un bien
qui était sur lequel les sols étaient
pollués voire les os étaient polluées
donc c'est ça la réalité il y a des
dizaines et des dizaines de familles en
France qui sont dans cette situation là
je parle de la France parce que si c'est
extra sur la situation métropolitaine
ce serait pareil en fait
[Musique]
c'est un village qui ne sachez pas et
qui ne se prend pas
sinon l'histoire d'accord vous me
raconterez
vous inquiétez pas que j'ai pas oublié
vos pratiques vertes et que j'étais on a
fait l'ouverture sur les après-mines sur
soundter et tal je voulais vous raconter
zentarités
les sites en cours d'exploitation et les
projets bon bien sûr c'est une
estimation et à la fin ils obtiennent
une surface à peu près à l'échelle
mondiale de 55000 km² de mémoire donc ça
c'est Hunter étal 2020 et dans cette
publication
ils disent bah écoutez l'emprise sur les
zones naturelles les forêts
donc principalement c'est des zones
naturelles protégées qui évoquent ainsi
que des zones de forêt des zones de
forêt primaires etc et très importantes
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait notamment lié au
projet qu'on envisage de développer pour
assurer la transition écologique et bien
du coup on va se retrouver dans des
espaces qui sont très reculés des zones
protégées des forêts primaires des zones
machin
et donc ils alertent sur ce point-là et
ensuite ils ajoutent une conclusion
qu'il faut bien en avoir en tête parce
que on pourra pas dire on nous l'avait
pas dit
ces auteurs disent
les conséquences
des activités minières menées pour le
compte de la dite transition énergétique
pourrait dépasser les impacts que l'on a
souhaité éviter avec la mise en place
des 10 dispositifs
[Rires]
si j'ai bien compris alors les impacts
qu'on a en gros les impacts qu'on a
[Musique]
[Rires]
sans vouloir trop exagéré donc voilà
donc ça c'est pour ça et donc après
effectivement vous avez évoqué un point
important c'est la question des efforts
alors la question des efforts déjà par
rapport à l'après mine il y aura jamais
assez d'efforts de fait puisque de fait
il s'agit de pollution qui sont pérennes
contrairement à ce que certains disent
c'est une perte nulle c'est une perte
systématique de biodiversité il y a
certains écrits et certaines personnes
qui prétendent notamment qu'on pourrait
avoir un regain biodiversité après
l'activité minière voilà il y a tiepont
étal 2011 il y a Goul de 2011 de type
2014 enfin bon il y a une ribambelle de
chercheurs qui vous explique que c'est
absolument faux c'est toujours une perte
de biodiversité après l'activité minière
donc ça sert à rien d'aller chercher du
gain de biodiversité après un site
billet bref donc c'est une perte et on
ne reviendra pas à l'état initial on ne
reviendra pas à l'état initial c'est
impossible une fois que ça on l'a bien
en tête
du coup il faut du coup se dire que
c'est pas une question de faire des
efforts c'est une question de
responsabilité l'exploitant minier
devrait être ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui en tous les cas c'est pas
comme ça que sont pensées les droits ce
n'est pas comme ça que son pensée la
fonctionnement des sites miniers n'est
pensé le fonctionnement des signes mais
l'État français enfin l'État français et
les autres États en fait devrait
justement contrecarrer ça en obligeant
en considérant en fait que c'est la
responsabilité de l'exploitant jusqu'à
la fin de la fin c'est lui qui a extrait
ces matériaux c'est donc lui qui a plus
personne qui va vouloir faire des trous
ah bah ça va être compliqué oui ça va
diminuer grandement l'intérêt pour
l'exploitation
climatique mais écoutez comme je vous le
disais avec l'exemple de zone turtles
tout à l'heure moi j'aimerais bien
savoir comment on va faire pour vivre
dans un environnement plus sain si on
diminue les gaz les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre si en parallèle on
développe l'activité minière ne cessez
pas vous allez avoir vous allez avoir
des
des conséquences alors déjà faut savoir
ce que vous voulez la petite dame vous
voulez respirez propre ou vous voulez
vous l'avez dans de l'eau propre
comme fournisse des maintenant qu'on
sait la quantité de métal en se basant
par exemple sur les scénarios de
Grégoire ivanaquin moi je peux pas le
faire j'ai pas les données j'ai une
équipe de 15 bénévoles et de salariés
dont moi on est limité donc je peux pas
donc j'appelle officiellement lors de
cette vidéo à toutes les personnes qui
le peuvent de monter à un groupe de
travail international on va se mettre
tous autour de la table et maintenant on
va quantifier les impacts
et on va regarder ce que disent
interétal parce que si effectivement les
impacts vont dépassent ce qu'on a essayé
de justement d'éviter enfin excusez-moi
mais vous avez pas l'impression que
c'est un peu Shadok notre histoire quand
même
vous inquiétez pas c'est surtout un tas
de sujets ici il est Shadoks on les
analyse de base
par contre le côté minier c'est un peu
comme le côté réchauffement climatique
ça commence à faire froid dans le dos
parce que là je vais vous couper
bon
nous ennuyez avec votre petite
ce côté un petit peu rebelle vous faites
des trous ça salit bon maintenant on va
aller chercher sous l'eau
tranquille il y aura plus de trous on va
pu voir il y aura de l'eau dessus ce
sera il y aura plus besoin de
[Musique]
réhabilités on va aller chercher des
nodules pollinitaliques alors ce serait
des agrégats au fond de l'eau qui
ressemble à des ballons de handball on
passe une petite moissonneuse on va
chercher ça c'est à 4000 mètres de fond
un peu moins ou un peu plus ça laisse
pas de trace tranquille et on peut
continuer à faire des selfies en bouche
de canard avec nos téléphones portables
et juste une question est-ce que vous
j'en connais je sais pas qu'est-ce que
vous connaissez la dimension d'un ballon
de handball
c'est grand commence
un à 12 cm pareil
mais 12 cm du coup ça fait une boule de
pétanque ou pas
je laisse les experts vérifier mais
c'est à 12 cm c'est ça alors oui
effectivement
la grande mode vis-à-vis des
problématiques posées par l'industrie
minière parce que effectivement on en a
pas parlé juste avant mais forcément ce
qu'on dit pas dans tout ce marasme c'est
que plus le temps avance plus on aimait
des gaz à effet de serre plus on pollue
plus c'est compliqué d'exploiter plus on
génère des émissions donc ça veut dire
que il y a aussi des phénomènes comme on
disait la question de d'être en capacité
de quantifier c'est aussi de regarder
des externalités ou des impacts en fait
qui sont plus immédiats et plus
comparables comme si je continue à
augmenter voir si je fais exploser la
demande métallique quelles vont être les
émissions en dioxyde de souffle et au
fond de remis métallique elles vont être
les émissions en termes de gaz à effet
de serre par rapport à toutes les
énergies fossiles qui vont être
nécessaires
c'est pour ça que j'insiste vraiment là
dessus en fait c'est qu'on peut même
faire comparaison à un pour un avec des
heures de grandeur c'est toujours
difficile de comparer la pollution d'un
cours d'eau avec des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et l'atténuation des
changements climatiques je l'entends
mais on pourrait même déjà réaliser
l'exercice à une échelle un pour un ne
serait-ce qu'au niveau des gaz à effet
de serre je ferme la parenthèse mais en
tous les cas effectivement oui on en
avait un petit peu parlé on avait
introduit le sujet lors de notre
dernière voilà rencontre et donc du coup
effectivement il y a ce grand plan qui
est basé alors on parle beaucoup des
nodules il y a trois types de gisements
les sulfures hydrothermaux qui sont
schématiquement liés à des phénomènes de
volcanisme sous-marins
c'est des évents volcaniques ça se fait
des petites cheminées et puis vous avez
en fait donc de l'eau qui circule dans
la croûte océanique ça remonte ça se
charge en métaux ça remonte en sortant
du coup ça précipite alors le gros du
panache va être disperser dans les eaux
de mer et puis il y a une partie qui va
se reposer sous forme de cheminée tout à
fait ça c'est sulfure hydrothermes
niveau de la dorsale médio Atlantique
ensuite dit la pauvre crevette quoi et
donc du coup vous avez
impossible
et nous du coup vous avez donc les
sulfurisdrothermants vous avez les
nodules que vous avez évoqué donc là
cette fois-ci on est dans des plaines
abyssales très profondes plusieurs
milliers de mètres de profondeur c'est
plusieurs milliers de mètres aussi de
profondeur pour les sulfuries
hydrothermaux
et là cette fois-ci en fait on est dans
des zones où il y a très peu de
sédimentation et donc effectivement vous
aviez évoqué la dent de requin la
dernière fois en fait effectivement vous
allez avoir ce qu'on appelle un nucléus
et alors là c'est un phénomène qui est
d'une finesse la géologie mais c'est
incroyable géologie en fait c'est la
formation des nodules c'est un phénomène
extraordinaire je vais vous le raconter
vous allez croire que je vous ment
tellement c'est incroyable en petite
boule de neige
[Rires]
vous avez du coup
je pleure et donc du coup vous avez le
nucléus et donc vous êtes on est
d'accord vous êtes très en profondeur
sur une pleine abyssale donc vous avez
de la vase et du sable et l'eau de mer
d'accord donc ce qui va se passer en
fait c'est que vous allez avoir des
phénomènes de concrétion d'oxyde de fer
et d'oxyde de manganèse tout fin tout
fin tout fin quand je dis tout fin c'est
nanométrique donc nanométrique c'est un
millième un millionième de millimètre
voilà donc c'est vraiment petit tout
petit c'est des tout petits grains
d'oxyde de fer qui vont effectivement
s'agréger les uns les autres et en fait
ces petits oxydes en fait vont aspirer
les métaux de l'eau de mer et de l'eau
qui se trouve dans les sédiments du sous
ce qu'on appelle l'autre porosité en
fait la vase et les sédiments il y a de
l'eau à l'intérieur ce qu'on appelle
l'autre porosité et en fait du coup ça
va aspirer ça et donc le métal va être
absorbé ou incorporé sur le petit oxyde
de fer ou oxyde de manganèse alors la
raison pour laquelle je vous raconte
cette histoire merveilleuse c'est que ça
avoir des sacrés implications derrière
et donc les en croûtements troisième
type de gisement donc nodule 1 à 12 cm
mise en place de ces petits phénomènes
de concrétion temps moyen c'est quelques
dizaines à quelques centaines de
millimètres concrétionnés par millions
d'années
c'est bien ça
donc c'est pas tous les quatre matins
qu'on va refaire des nodules et ensuite
vous allez les encroutement c'est le
même principe que les nodules sauf que
là on est pas sur une petite boule en
fait on va se placer sur des fonds
sous-marins donc des zones de relief des
volcans des choses comme ça des voilà
des reliefs et en fait on va mettre la
on va mettre en place une croûte
similaire sur en fait les fonds marins
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle les
encourements et c'est la même
composition globalement que c'est la
même composition que que les nodules
voilà comment on fait pour évaluer ce
que ça va nous rapporter
je les écoute je vois des rapports
passés on a plein de métaux il y en a
partout au fond de la mer c'est
vachement bien alors moi j'ai tendance à
les croire mais comment on fait pour
évaluer la densité de quelle quantité on
va pouvoir sortir
est très controversé je me suis posé la
même question que vous sauf que du coup
bah avec 6 textes on a pris le temps de
regarder dans le détail parce que on
était assez alors effectivement il y a
peut-être un chiffre que vous vous avez
peut-être en tête notamment c'est un
chiffre qui est très très donné enfin
qui est très souvent fourni dans les
presses françaises quel que soit les
presses toutes sortes c'est 34 milliards
de tonnes dans la zone de Clarion
Clipperton 34 milliards de tonnes de
nodules dans la zone de Clarion
Clipperton vous tapez 34 milliards de
tonnes de nodules sur Google vous avez
plein plein plein plein de papiers qui
sortent 34 milliards de tonnes
déjà ce chiffre s'est passé aujourd'hui
34 milliards de tonnes de nodules déjà
34 milliards de tonnes de nuls c'est un
gros morceau
je sais pas ce que les gens là si les
gens se voient ce que ça fait un
milliard de tonnes c'est énorme ici même
si c'est très dense on s'entend un
noduler les dents mais enfin quand même
bon bref donc tout ça pour dire que du
coup 34 milliards de tonnes dans la zone
de Clarion Clipperton donc alors je vais
vous raconter du coup globalement donc
on est d'accord c'est différents types
alors la zone de Clarion Clipperton en
l'occurrence alors globalement les
gisements les trouve dans tous les
océans
Océan Indien aussi on peut suffire aussi
Atlantique globalement on les trouve
partout par contre il est vrai que
l'océan Pacifique et celui et l'océan
qui dispose du des réserves les plus
prometteuses voilà donc pour l'instant
je vais le dire que comme ça d'accord à
l'intérieur vous avez notamment deux les
deux principaux gisements et de nodules
et donc hautement pour les nodules c'est
la zone de Clarion Clipperton qui se
trouve entre le Mexique et Hawaii donc
nord du passé de l'océan Pacifique et au
sud-ouest de cette zone là donc pas très
loin vous avez la primecrustzone
qui est là du coup c'est là c'est
l'équivalent de la zone de Clarion
Clipperton mais pour les encrûtements
c'est vraiment le nirvana si vous voulez
mais du coup faut pas le traduire parce
que sinon ça casse tout c'est la prime
creuse voilà et nous aussi si vous dites
la zone de première course c'est
horrible voilà donc c'est les voilà
c'est la zone où il y a les encrûtements
les plus riches bon ça ça se trouve dans
l'océan Pacifique mais sachez encore une
fois qu'il y a d'autres gisements
ailleurs et donc du coup alors non c'est
intéressé à deux choses si pour avoir
beaucoup de métal il faut soit que ce
soit très très riche donc la
concentration soit très élevée c'est à
dire que vous pouvez avoir un petit
tonnage c'est une quantité totale de
minerais faible si vous avez une très
grosse concentration si 50% de tout le
minerai c'est du métal c'est banco vous
avez pas besoin de beaucoup de tonnage
les dealers de drogues connaissent bien
le principe à cause de la réglementation
ils font de la concentration de
substances
parce que comme ça quand ils sont chopés
par la douane ça fait que 1 kg sauf que
la concentration c'est pas l'herbe de
Mai 68
[Rires]
il est très bon j'ai discuté très
récemment avec des douaniers d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça d'où la vision à la
concentration
j'ai aucune compétence dans le domaine
on t'explique zéro donc du coup tout ça
pour dire que
donc en fait vous avez donc la zone de
Clarion Clipperton et la prime creuse
zone donc ces deux grandes zones et
comme je vous disais du coup
au niveau des sulfures hydrothermaux
l'une des zones les plus connues c'est
la zone de Atlantis qui se trouve au
niveau de la mer Noire de mémoire ou de
la mer Rouge pardon je vous dis
peut-être des bêtises bon gros qui se
trouve là là je le vois là au sud du
Moyen-Orient là très bien voilà rouge
et c'est Atlantis je crois que ça
s'appelle Atlantis ou Atlantis 2 et
c'est une grande zone de sulfureur
et donc tout ça pour dire que du coup
donc au niveau des teneurs on s'est
d'abord intéressé aux teneurs
c'est-à-dire qu'elle est la
concentration dans les métaux
qui nous intéressent dans les
différentes types de gisements combien
de mètres carrés je suis obligé de
moissonner pour me faire un panneau
solaire
faut déjà vous intéresser à la teneur
parce que si on vous dit que la séisme
est très riche vous n'aurez pas besoin
de moissonner beaucoup forcément donc du
coup Bruno la teneur en fait déjà la
grande surprise première grande surprise
que nous on a une c'est que la plupart
va se passer vous voyez un peu les
presses ou la façon dont on en parle
mais on en parle beaucoup à soi avec
beaucoup d'emphase et du coup on
finirait presque par croire qu'il y a
des métaux incroyables dans les fonds
marins que c'est pas du tout des métaux
de base ou c'est pas du tout des métaux
connus envoyer un peu il y a un espèce
d'imaginaire que je trouve que c'est un
petit peu créé en fait pas du tout c'est
des métaux le on ne peut plus connu en
fait les principaux métaux d'intérêt
pour les sulfurets thermaux c'est hors
argent cuisinent connu quoi et pour et
les encrûtements et les nodules c'est
manganèse nickel Kobal cuivre
concentration alors les concentrations
là-dedans c'est soit dans la gamme des
gisements terrestres soit en dessous des
gisements terrestres
vous parlez de la référence il y a 1850
ou on se penchait on ramasser des
référence actualisée si ce texte août
les concentrations sont extrêmement
faibles donc si vous voulez des exemples
encore plus précis
je peux vous donner par exemple donc
dans la zone de Clarion Clipperton et
dans la zone de la paix CZ donc dans cet
ordre typiquement donc ça c'est une des
données de aïnetal 2013 un grand pape de
la géologie et des ressources marines à
l'international du coup en fait à une
étape vous dit que donc sur la zone de
Clarion Clipperton donc au niveau du
cobalt je suis en train de regarder mes
rapports et mes notes je vous dis ça
tout de suite c'est 0,21%
pour la prime cross zone c'est 0,67 % et
la concentration dans les gisements
terrestres actualisé de août 2022 c'est
001 à 1%
0 voilà donc voilà donc vous êtes dans
la gamme
globalement vous êtes dans la gamme mais
vous n'êtes pas énorme quoi je veux dire
c'est 0,21
0,21 et 0,67 quoi donc on n'est pas très
au-dessus c'est des concentrations pour
le exploiter
du coup après voilà donc ça c'est pour
vous donner un ordre de grandeur par
contre vous avez d'autres métaux donc
ils sont pas des métaux d'intérêt sans
sous stricto dans le sens où c'est pas
les premiers métaux pour lesquels on va
tels que ceux que je vous ai listé mais
c'est des métaux d'intérêt potentiels on
espère pouvoir les trouver aussi
potentiellement donc là on les a aussi
regardés et on a totalement regardé des
métaux qui ont tout le monde parle donc
notamment par exemple le lithium on
parle beaucoup donc de lithium dans les
nodules polymétalliques donc dans les
nœuds on va les appeler les nodules peu
importe qui soit polymétrie c'est des
nodules dans les nodules de la zone de
Clarion Clipperton alors là du coup la
concentration en lithium c'est 131 g par
tonnes les teneurs dans les Salars c'est
500 à 1500 et ça peut monter jusqu'à
15000 dans les gisements primaires
autant vous dire que 131 et alors les
terres rares dont tout le monde parle
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps et notamment dans la prime creuse
zone
concentration des terres dans la prime
creuse zone donc en croûtement 0,25%
teneur des gisements mondiaux 5 à 10
l'affaire est donc réglée il y a pas
d'intérêt aller chercher le lithium et
terreur dans cette affaire là l'affaire
est donc réglée donc en tous les cas
l'intérêt pour ces gisements ne se situe
visiblement pas à emploiement vous avez
pas donné les deux exceptions que vous
avez identifié dans votre tableau madame
Stéphane donc je vais le dire comme ça
c'est dit exception faite de ce que je
viens de vous dire du cuivre dans les
sulfures hydrothermaux la moyenne
internationale des sulfures
hydrothermaux étant de 5% de cuivre
alors que les teneurs mondiales étaient
entre dans les yeux m'intéresse étant
entre 0,3 et 2% et exception faite
également du tellure qui est dans les
encourements de la PC de 60 grammes par
tonne alors que dans les gisements
terrestre mondiaux la teneur moyenne en
tellure est entre 0,01 et 1 g par tonne
je répète la
teneurs je pense qu'il y a des gens qui
doivent halluciner quand je vous envoie
ces chiffres c'est 001 à 1 g par tonne
de tellure dans les gisements mondiaux
donc voilà donc exception faite de ces
deux-là donc ça c'est en tous les cas
exception faite de ces deux substances
par rapport à toutes celles que nous
avons étudié force et de constater que
l'intérêt n'est pas au niveau de la
teneur donc comme vous le disiez
précédemment on va donc du coup de voir
compenser par une exploitation sur de
grandes échelles on fait des gros des
grandes quantités pourquoi je parle de
grandes échelles tout de suite les
sulfures hydrothermaux c'est des
cheminées isolés maximum 45 mètres
parfois elle peut faire un mètre 2 m
maximum 45 mètres ce sont des petits
amas vous voyez en ponctuel donc c'est
pas en fait un petit amende
la bouche qui qui crache de
de l'eau là où elle a été de crevettes
et mes couilles
et des crabes exceptionnelles qui ne se
trouvent nulle part ailleurs dans le
monde
on arrive on prend sa petite sa petite
maison et voilà c'est terminé et puis ça
se refait non combien ça grandit comment
les plus
légisments les plus gros ça c'est des
données décoristes 2014
annexes A de mémoire les gisements les
plus gros
c'est plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'années pour les pour les faire ça
c'est pour les sulfure hydrothermes
et comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
on en parlait pour les nodules c'est
quelques quelques
millimètres à quelques centaines de
millimètres par million d'années et
s'agissant des encrûtements on a un
chiffre beaucoup plus précis c'est 1 à 6
mm par million d'années et à la fin du
coup vous avez donc une couche possible
de nodule sur 12 cm
où vous avez sinon une croûte sur des
reliefs sous-marins qui va faire entre 1
mm et 260 mm donc 26 cm donc vous voyez
c'est tout petit en fait donc que ce
soit les cheminées qui effectivement
être grande mais qui sont plutôt
disparate vous voyez que ce soit les
nodules qui sont une couche de maximum
12 cm qu'il faut récupérer à 4000 mètres
de profondeur que ce soit les
encouragements qui sont sur des reliefs
des flancs de volcans des mondes et
machins qui se trouvent sur des
épaisseurs et ça fait 26 cm ça va être
très très compliqué effectivement alors
je mets des palmes à mon poney si tu
bats
et on y va avec 3000 chevaux électrique
sous l'eau
ça ressemble à quoi une machine pour
récolter tout ça alors c'est pas la même
méthode pour alors déjà on va prendre on
va sur les trois on va prendre les
encroutements les encouragements on sait
pas faire
les encourements on sait pas faire parce
qu'en fait le problème c'est qu'on a une
couche indurée qui repose sur un
substrat rocheux et du coup ça va être
compliqué de laisser séparer non mais
passons oui et non j'insiste quand même
je me permets d'insister parce que ça
veut dire que quand on vous parle donc
crottement bah c'est pas très honnête si
on commence pas par vous dire je sais
pas comment exploiter ce machin ça fait
des beaux chiffres dans la presse
il faut être honnête on ne sait pas
exploiter ses encourements le problème
c'est que c'est comme une croûte de fer
qu'on a mis sur de la roche
donc à un moment donné le seul moyen
c'est je suis désolé et ben c'est la
Dinan c'est la dynamite et du coup
dynamite académie de profondeur ça va
être compliqué donc ou sinon il faut des
machines qui sont assez
donc voilà donc du coup pour l'instant
si vous voulez du coup on va laisser les
encrûtements de côté donc après vous
avez
globalement c'est toujours le même
concept c'est ce que vous avez décrit
c'est-à-dire non pas un râteau mais vous
avez un système de collecte dans les
fonds marins donc ça c'est toujours
valable pour les trois types de
gisements dans tous les cas on le sait
un système de levage pour remonter le
minerai
une tondeuse à gazon alors effectivement
vous souvenez quand je vous avais
raconté le coup des robots dans la
piscine
si la dernière fois je croyais que je
vous avais dit je croyais que c'était
des robots dans la piscine moi je
croyais que c'était tout petit alors je
vais vous raconter une histoire du coup
les sulfures hydrothermaux parce que
point aussi important on a parlé des
encouragements pour lesquels il n'y
avait pas aujourd'hui d'exploitation
mais il faut aussi savoir que à
l'échelle internationale il n'y a pas de
projet minier dans les fonds marins en
exploitation aucun c'est quoi c'est dans
le domaine du rêve est-ce que c'est dans
le domaine pour ne vous inquiétez pas on
va trouver tous les métaux qu'il faut du
coup je réponds à votre question juste
après mais je peux vous le dire il y en
a pas promis je vous réponds le domaine
du rêve mais donc du coup effectivement
il y a pas de mais même dans les zones
économiques exclusives il y a pas il y a
pas de projet en exploitation donc
effectivement on peut quand même se
reposer sur un projet d'exploration qui
avait été bien avancé quelle progrès
solwarin qui devait avoir lieu dans la
zone économique exclusive de la
Papouasie Nouvelle Guinée plus
particulièrement dans la mer de Bismarck
et qui était un projet d'exploitation de
sulfure et de retard mot donc on peut
éventuellement se rendre compte de ce
que ça peut donner donc pur hydrothermo
en l'occurrence du coup donc vous avez
trois machines un auxiliarique cutter ou
un découpeur auxiliaire qui en fait une
grosse machine qui va découper
grossièrement le gisement
chose à continuer aux crevettes de
soleil j'espère il pensait il y en a une
de la part d'une directrice de
l'environnement d'une exploration d'une
société exploratoire
donc du coup vous avez donc ce qu'on
appelle l'auxiliarrie cutter ensuite
vous avez le bulk cutter ou le découpeur
en masse alors son pauvre le pauvre en
fait c'est lui qui fait le travail de
précision de la découpe de gisement et
ensuite vous avez le troisième c'est le
collecte machine on appelle donc
l'appareil de collecte qui lui en fait
va aspirer avant de le ramener sur la
conduite de levage qui va rejoindre les
vaisseaux qu'on appelle les vaisseaux de
soutien à la production et qui
fonctionnent en longueur de temps voilà
parce que du coup c'est la conduite de
levage du minerai qui doit être relié
entre aux environs 3 4000 mètres de
profondeur jusqu'à jusqu'à la surface
bon
donc il faut savoir en fait que ces
machines en fait comme je l'ai dit moi
je pensais que c'est des robots dans la
piscine j'évite des chanter puisque
effectivement je vous avais dit la
dernière fois c'est énorme donc si on
prend le cas de sol wara c'est trois
machines là elles font entre 180 et 280
tonnes pour une puissance installée de
1,8 à 2,5 MW mais ces données je les
tiens de parianos 2016 pariano ce qui
est un monsieur qui a présenté en fait
le projet de sol warhin et donc je me
base sur ces infographies et sur ces
données donc du coup vous imaginez alors
vous me dites je sais absolument pas moi
je sais pas ce que c'était ces trucs là
donc du coup je me suis pas laissé
démonter et je suis allée chercher les
plus gros tomberaux dans l'industrie
minière vous savez ces espèces de
monstre là et j'ai franchement j'ai fait
ça un peu à l'ancienne quoi je suis
allée sur google et j'ai tapé plus gros
et plus puissant tombereau dans le mode
mini et voyez un peu en mode
tout à fait ça et donc parmi les
publications je tombe sur le liberte
282b
vous savez la marque allemande leader
t282b
le liberté 282 en l'occurrence c'est
l'un des plus grands et l'un des plus
puissants tombereau ou dumper si on
prend le terme anglais au monde
il a été conçu pour l'industrie minière
pour se rendre compte de qu'est-ce que
j'entends par grand ce truc fait alors
ce truc fait 14 mètres de long il fait 8
mètres de large et 7 mètres de haut 8,8
mètres de large de mémoire il fait 7
mètres de haut donc vous allez me dire
c'est super grand bah oui c'est super
grand c'est incroyable c'est un monstre
le truc à charge en vide il est à 200
tonnes un chargé vide il peut porter
jusqu'à 600 tonnes de mémoire dans sa
capacité maximale enfin c'est un monstre
quoi c'est un monstre et pour la petite
histoire vous savez ces pneus il pèse
ils font 4 mètres de diamètre il pèse 5
tonnes parce que j'ai du coup je me suis
renseignée sur le liberté 280
je regarde ses spécifications auteur
largeur longueur puissance installée et
puissance installée ces 2,7 mégawatts
et là je compare ces spécifications avec
le Bull que cutter la deuxième machine
quasiment la même chose
et on va envoyer ces machines là
à 4000 mètres de profondeur bon moi
parce que les gisements hydro de
sulfurydrothermaux sont moins profonds
mais on va dire entre eux autour de
allez on va dire 1500 entre allez 1500
2500 mètres de profondeur quoi
bon donc déjà ça c'est ça et après pour
les nodules en fait vous avez ce qu'on
appelle un collecteur actif qui doit en
fait aspirer
donc pareil il a une conduite il est
relié à la conduite de levage et il doit
aspirer en fait les nodules alors on
parle d'un collecteur
actif et non pas un collecteur passif
parce que les collecteurs passifs ont
été essayés c'était le râteau en fait ce
que vous disiez donc c'est d'ailleurs en
fait on envisageait de mettre une benne
vous savez avec une ligne quoi un peu
comme la pêche à la ligne on met la
benne au fond et on tire et on va bien
récupérer les les petits nodules qui se
trouvent en fond quoi au pire on
ramènera du sédiment alors ça marche pas
du tout on récupère beaucoup trop de
sédiments ça va pas du tout donc on met
en a mis en place plutôt des collecteurs
actifs
où là en fait on va commencer à prêter à
l'intérieur de la petite machine donc on
va commencer à séparer l'eau les
sédiments des nodules quoi
et on les on les range on les range dans
une benne et cette benne en fait elle
est aspirée en continu vers le navire de
soutien à la production sachant que du
coup nous on a regardé on a dit mais
l'énergie que ces deux trucs demandent
parce que bon on s'entend que vous allez
pas faire fonctionner
3650 chevaux ou un équivalent donc c'est
à dire en puissance installée 2,5
mégawatts pour un bull queuteur ils sont
trois mais bon rien que pour lui celui
du milieu 2,5 MW on va pas le faire
fonctionner avec des éoliennes qu'on va
mettre sur une île flottante à
l'intérieur de l'océan Pacifique donc il
faut des hydrocarbures il faut des
hydrocarbures il faut des centrales et
il faut alors bien sûr on va voir bien
sûr alors évidemment on s'entend le
navire ne va pas fonctionner avec des
éoliennes donc c'est pour l'instant ce
que nous on en lit notamment les travaux
d'agawalital 2012 disent ce sera
principalement des génératrices à diesel
donc des bateaux et pourquoi pas un
petit réacteur du clair
écoutez pourquoi pas
encore tout essayé comme ça on pourra
dire qu'on aura tout essayé
[Musique]
[Rires]
du coup voilà les principaux gisements
de Dieu les situés entre 4100 et 4800 et
4200 mètres de profondeur donc même
remonter des entre guillemets petite
masse mais c'est pas du tout des petites
masses hein qu'on va remonter il faut
les remonter là haut donc du coup c'est
ça qui demande c'est sur le bateau c'est
sous l'eau alors du coup actuellement ce
qui est dit c'est que en tous les cas
sur le prêt traitement parce que dans
tous les cas quel que soit le type de
gisement il faut faire un prétraitement
par déshydratation parce que du coup
vous avez beaucoup d'eau de l'eau marine
et puis vous avez aussi des sédiments
qu'il faut déjà séparer quitte les
sulfuris de rotermo quitte les
encouratements quittent les nodules de
du sable de la vase des autres petits
cailloux etc et ça du coup alors l'idée
notamment il y a un certain nombre de
propositions qui ont été faites
notamment au chromovic chez tal 2021 qui
fait des propositions du coup Agawa
létal aussi on parle de mémoire en 2012
en fait ils font des propositions de
prétraitement directement au fond donc
directement dans les machines
c'est-à-dire les machines qui collectent
font le prétraitement par déshydratation
c'est comme ça que ça ça c'est une
première la possibilité la deuxième
possibilité c'est qu'on remonte la masse
en entier alors effectivement ça demande
plus hydrocarbures c'est plus compliqué
mais par contre du coup vous pouvez
faire le traitement sur le bateau voilà
deux possibilités par contre ce qui est
sur c'est que le prétraitement ce sera
fait en mer ce qui fait que si c'est au
fond et ben les rejets liés à cette
séparation se feront en mer au fond de
l'eau si c'est sur le bateau on peut
mettre en place ce qu'on appelle une
conduite de réinjection ou en fait on va
réintroduire alors deux préférences
au-delà de 1000 mètres de profondeur en
tous les cas c'est ce que les chercheurs
expliquent en disant s'il vous plaît
essayez de pas mettre ça trop en surface
mais de toute façon ça change rien les
dommages vont être similaires
réintroduire en fait les matériaux au
fond donc plutôt vers 1000 mètres de
profondeur donc conduite de réinjection
et donc ça c'est que la partie vous les
avez juste collectés mais la question
que vous pourriez légitimement vous
poser c'est de me dire et ben du coup
écouter là pour l'instant moi j'ai juste
des raisons complètement j'ai juste des
sulfures hydrotteins moi j'ai des amas
j'ai toujours pas de métal ça fait pas
des voitures mais notre affaire donc si
je veux faire des voitures ou si je veux
faire j'en sais rien moi des machines
j'ai quand même besoin de d'étapes
ultérieure et alors ça c'est
complètement passé sous silence c'est
drôle les gens ils parlent toujours de
la collecte de comment on va au fond du
fait que c'est difficile qui a 600 bars
alors que la pression atmosphérique
c'est un bas qui fait 1,5 degrés donc il
fait très très froid machin tout le
monde parle de l'exploitation et
personne se dit pour l'instant je n'ai
ramené sur le bateau que des nodules
j'ai que du caillou là donc là on y
est et vous vous souvenez cette histoire
que je vous racontais sur les nodules le
site petit grain finement imbriqué etc
vous croyez que le métal cette fois-ci
la le récupérer cette échelle là
ça marche pas non plus et non non non et
donc du coup et ben en fait il y a pas
d'équivalent terrestre de ces minerais
il y a pas d'équivalent pour traiter
pour le travail en type c'est à dire en
termes de texture c'est tellement fin
vous imaginez vous imaginez en fait
c'est des donc des grains nanométriques
on a dit millionième de millimètres qui
sont collés les uns aux autres finement
imbriqués et on a un absorbé donc on a
on a collé des métaux sous forme
d'atomes ou de molécules donc en
l'occurrence sous forme d'ion c'est à
dire des atomes ou des molécules chargés
c'est ça qui à l'intérieur comme étal
c'est c'est pour ça qu'on va dans les
fonds quand moi j'ai découvert ça mais
j'ai dit mais qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette imposture j'ai vérifié plusieurs
fois à une étal 2021 à une étoile 2013 a
été au chromovitch 2014 j'ai vérifié
toutes mes publications chromobile 2021
je dis mais c'est quand même une blague
et ben non
c'est pour ça qu'on va au fond c'est
pour aller récupérer des métaux qui sont
sous forme de d'atomes ou de molécules
chargées à coller à des grains d'oxyde
de fer ou d'oxyde de manganèse qui sont
eux-mêmes de taille nanométriques de
cuivre
à traiter mais ça on vous en parle
jamais donc qu'est-ce que vous disent
les auteurs à une échoinsky 2018 vous
dise on sait pas traité on a des tests
mais on sait pas faire en fait mais ce
qui est bien normal il y a pas
d'équivalent vous vous rendez compte en
plus c'est compliqué il y a énormément
d'eau à l'intérieur il y a une très
forte porosité c'est extrêmement
compliqué à traiter et ça personne n'en
parle mais il faut absolument en parler
puisque le traitement qui va être
nécessaire pour la récupération du métal
dont on parle le temps dans nos débats
en fait mais ça va être l'étape qui va
arriver après et ça on ne sait pas faire
aujourd'hui alors il y a des
possibilités que ce soit pour les
sulfuries de rotermaux ou que ce soit
pour les nodules pour les encouragements
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment encore à la
traîne donc il y a des possibilités il y
a des pilotes mais il y a absolument
rien bien sûr d'établi mais vous êtes
sûr parce que je vois mal un industriel
lever des fonds je vois mal la journée
ou un politique parlé de cette immense
ressource
alors que c'est que du flan il y a
forcément un truc
dans le cadre du projet montagneux on
vous a dit qu'on allait exploiter des
sulfures de fer et des sulfures de fer
et de cuivre avec de l'or sous forme
d'atomes et des particules de fait d'or
inférieures à 50 microns il y a personne
qui a bronché pour une teneur moyenne de
je sais plus un ou deux grammes par
tonnes
minéralogiste puisque c'est leur métier
un spécialiste dans la concentration des
minerais et bien il faut
en fait il faut complètement briser le
réseau cristallin faut briser le réseau
cristal c'est à dire que du coup bah il
faut là faut y aller
la faut y aller en force donc c'est à
dire que du coup
d'après ce que j'en ai lu encore une
fois tout ça est à l'état de test
actuellement il est fait mention alors
plus pour les nodules il est fait
mention de combinaison dix de voix dites
Pyro métallurgiques et hydrométalurgique
donc on est plutôt en Pyro métalgés
c'est-à-dire qu'il va falloir fondre le
minerai sur des températures qui
seraient autour de 1300 1400 degrés
Celsius et puis en parallèle faire de
l'hydrométallurgie donc actuellement ce
qu'on appelle l'hydrome métallurgie donc
là ça va être de la lixiviation c'est à
dire qu'on va mettre le minerai broyé
sécher broyé pour les nodules il faut
les sécher d'abord sinon on a un
problème on a trop d'eau à l'intérieur
donc il faut les sécher il faut les
broyer inférieur à micron donc inférieur
à un dixième de millimètre
ça fait pas de poussière du tout il faut
broyer ça ça fait pas de poussière ce
qu'on fait tout on voit que d'ailleurs
et donc il faut broyer tout ça ensuite
du coup il faut les soumettre à des
bains alors c'est soit actuellement les
les acides qui sont privilégiés c'est
acide sulfurique ou acide chlorhydrique
ou de mémoire c'est un
c'est un acide basé à base d'ammonium et
de carbonate donc je crois que c'est 3
options là et la voie privilégiée ce
serait de faire les devoirs enfin la
façon de traiter ce miracles et la voix
dites pyrométallurgique et la voix dites
hydrométhagène vous vous rendez compte à
grand renfort d'énergie donc du coup
puisqu'il va falloir mettre énormément
de chaleur on va pas faire monter la
température à 1500 degrés dans le par
exemple la cuve dans lesquelles on
travaille comme ça ou 1400 degrés 1350
1450 degrés de mémoire donc il va
falloir mettre beaucoup d'énergie pour
ça beaucoup d'énergie aussi pour
permettre cette lixiviation dont on
parlait donc libérer il faut libérer le
métal quoi donc ça c'est extrêmement
important parce qu'en fait s'il y a pas
ça il y a pas de métal enfin faut quand
même être clair quoi ça je préfère un
système là-dessus et alors ça c'est le
parent pauvre des discussions sur les
exploitations en mer et donc je me
souviens que j'avais discuté avec une
personne qui m'interrogeait sur les
questions des fonds marins et puis elle
me disait bon bah du coup une fois que
c'est les nodules on est bon je dis vous
avez déjà vu des véhicules électriques
fonctionnaient avec des nodules on aura
des ça sera des nodules contre des
nodules mais non il faut récupérer le et
pourquoi vous n'en parlez pas il faut
absolument que vous parliez du processus
de récupération d'autant que bien que
les processus ne soient pas encore bien
mis en place c'est-à-dire qu'on manque
encore de visibilité on sait déjà que ce
sera plus énergivore que les traitements
actuels qui sont déjà particulièrement
énergies on le sait ça les chercheurs
sont tous d'accord pour vous dire ils le
savent que ça va être encore plus
énergivant pour faire fonctionner ce
type d'installation de traitement du
minerai il faudrait avoir une énergie en
très grande quantité et à bas coût sauf
erreur de ma part ce n'est pas dans
cette configuration que nous nous
situons actuellement à l'international
donc ça va être très problématique donc
cette partie du traitement ça passe
voilà ah oui ça passe et donc pour finir
de répondre à votre question précédente
donc du coup effectivement c'est très
compliqué à traiter je ne parle pas
comme on disait il faut des navires de
soutien à la production on est souvent à
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres des
côtes donc il faut qu'il y ait des
bateaux qui transit puis des bateaux qui
stationnent il faut qu'ils stationnent
donc c'est un énorme
donc ça demande énormément d'énergie
énormément de combustibles fossiles donc
ça il faut vraiment l'avoir en tête et
ensuite du coup il y a la c'est
effectivement cette question de quantité
totale qui pose question puisque je vous
disais tout à l'heure les 34 milliards
de tonnes de 3 alors certains oui
d'autres non alors si on prend les 34
milliards de tonnes moi personnellement
je ne me base pas sur les 34 milliards
de tonnes avec 6 textes vont se base pas
sur ces chiffres on se base en fait sur
les 21 milliards de tonnes c'est le
chiffre qui est retenu par aïnetal 2013
34 milliards de tonnes c'est un chiffre
plutôt qu'on utilise en France gardons
pour la cCZ les 21 milliards de tonnes
d'accord 21,1 milliards de tonnes alors
le produit fini alors de nodule
21,1 milliard de tonnes de nodules au
niveau de la zone de Clarion Clipperton
alors j'ai mis longtemps à trouver d'où
venaient ces chiffres parce que moi je
voulais savoir comment ils a calculé
21,1 milliard de tonnes
donc en gros la zone de Clarion
Clipperton c'est à peu près 9 millions
de kilomètres carrés c'est
ça fait trois fois la surface de l'Inde
la surface de l'un de ces 3,29 millions
de kilomètres carrés
. c'est grand c'est très très grand
[Rires]
je l'ai pris au Chili du nord au sud
c'est très très long
avec de la coca ou son coca non et sans
coca oui
et donc du coup
tout ça pour dire que donc en
l'occurrence en fait donc ça fait 9
millions de kilomètres carrés c'est très
très grand comme surface et donc en
l'occurrence c'est donner qui sont
utilisées encore une fois les 21,1
milliards je ne garde pas le chiffre qui
est toujours utilisé de 34 milliards
pour moi il est pas bon je préfère me
baser sur les chiffres qui font fois à
l'international en fait vient d'une
autorité qui est assez connue dans le
milieu c'est en anglais l'international
cybède à auto-ity en français l'autorité
internationale des fonds marins qui a
mandaté une étude en 2010 pour évaluer
la quantité le potentiel de nodules qui
se trouvait au niveau de la zone de
Clarion Clipperton et en fait ce qu'ils
ont fait c'est ce qu'on appelle alors
c'est pas une règle de trois ça reste un
modèle mathématique c'est ce qu'on
appelle du criage très utilisé dans les
premiers modèles dans le domaine minier
c'est à dire le crija je suis une
méthode géostatistique en fait c'est que
vous avez des points sur lesquels vous
avez des données et vous avez du au
centre vous avez pas de données pour
essayer de savoir ce que vous avez au
centre vous allez faire de
l'interpolation de données à partir des
points où vous avez des connaissances
des informations c'est ça le criage
alors ce qui a rendu l'exercice
difficile dans ce cas là c'est la taille
de la zone parce que même si vous avez
100 points 200 points 300 points sur 9
millions de kilomètres carrés c'est
compliqué donc Lisa en fait à réduit la
taille à 3,83 millions de kilomètres
carrés c'est quand même toujours plus
grand que l'Inde et ils ont dit il y a
21,1 milliards de tonnes de nodules dans
cette zone
alors tout le monde applaudit à demain
même avec une teneur donc on disait
teneur en coballe de mémoire à une étale
2022 2013 0 21%, mais 0,21% de cobalt
que multiplie vous rendez compte 21
milliards de tonnes de nodules c'est
gigantesque c'est gigantesque alors déjà
c'est du grisage c'est un modèle
mathématique qui
plein plein d'erreurs donc ça veut dire
que il faut prendre déjà ce 21,1
milliard avec énormément de précautions
et d'ailleurs c'est dans le rapport
c'est indiqué il faut prendre faut faire
beau frais très attention avec ce genre
de méthode c'est si vous voulez en
termes de ressources minières c'est ce
qu'on appelle des ressources minières
présumées le niveau le plus faible de
connaissance que vous ayez sur une
ressource vous voyez c'est vraiment un
tout petit niveau de connaissance vous
êtes vraiment pas sûr de votre coup
encore si vous imaginez Lisa lui-même
dit qu'il est pas sûr pour les 21
milliards autant vous dire que ça vous
donne quel crédit on peut apporter aux
34 milliards qu'on voit partout dans les
presses françaises
françaises en lui disant et Kevin ils
sont pas bons les chiffres là
on fait des gros rapports qui sont super
bien illustrés super bien expliqué on
les on leur incite à lire nos rapports
donc du coup effectivement
nos 21 milliards de tonnes donc ça c'est
pour ça et après effectivement les
autres estimations alors après vous avez
des estimations notamment il y a une
publication
qui a été faite par Fouquet en 2013 par
exemple qui évalue à du coup 3 milliards
de tonnes la quantité de sulfure
hydrothermaux au niveau des dorsales de
mémoire 3 milliards de tonnes alors là
pour le coup c'est une règle de trois
c'est une règle de trois pieds avec des
hypothèses qui sont alors vraiment
vraiment
on va dire
comment dit-on des hypothèses très
conservatoires c'est à dire qu'ils sont
un peu
justement pardon pas conservatoire qui
sont un petit peu comment dire un petit
peu trop optimiste finalement voilà et
vous avez notamment en fait des d'autres
chercheurs comme hamington etal en 2011
qui ont qui ont justement proposé
d'autres modèles on n'est plus à 3
milliards de tonnes au niveau des
sulfuries d'hydrothermes est plutôt
autour de 600 millions de tonnes voilà
mais en tous les cas ce que moi je peux
vous en dire c'est que on a regardé un
certain nombre de scénarios et un
certain nombre de chercheurs ce qui est
inquiétant c'est ce que vous décriviez
c'est à dire que du coup les gens vous
disent bah j'ai 21 milliards de tonnes
dans la CC zen donc la zone de Clarion
Clipperton que je multiplie par des
teneurs même si elles sont faibles on
l'a dit précédemment mais du coup ça
fait déjà des gros tonnages et après on
s'autorise mais c'est écrit dans les
publications on s'autorise à les
comparer avec des quantités consommées
donc ça je sais pas ça représente tant
d'années de la consommation européenne
autant d'années de la consommation
française ou avec les réserves
terrestres mais déjà ça n'a aucun sens
vous n'avez déjà pas vous n'avez déjà
pas déjà de base sur les teneurs vous
avez des teneurs moyennes vous allez pas
me dire enfin je suis géologue vous avez
pas me dire que la teneur dans les
nodules elle est homogène sur 9 millions
de kilomètres carrés ça n'a aucun sens
aucun sens donc ça se trouve le 0,67
c'est relativement optimiste donc on en
sait rien donc déjà sur les teneurs on
est bancal même si on dit allez je garde
les chiffres des teneurs comme hypothèse
de départ parce qu'il faut bien que je
fixe une variable les tonnages c'est à
la vague que je te la pousse excusez-moi
de l'expression comment c'est calculé
quoi donc le grisage bon globalement on
le sait et effectivement les auteurs
attention à Lisa le précise bien Lisa
dit attention à ses valeurs c'est du
crijal c'est un modèle mathématique on
n'a pas beaucoup de points c'est un
modèle mais le fait est qu'on a pas
d'autres modèles aujourd'hui et on part
sur ces modèles là donc autant il est
important si les gens le souhaitent
d'avoir une estimation des réserves si
le et de ce qui est au fond pourquoi pas
admettons mais surtout ne le pas le
comparer avec une consommation ça ne
veut rien dire ça ne veut et encore
moins avec des réserves terrestres et
réserves terrestres sur la transition
énergétique
on fait des plans sur la comète
et ça se passe tranquille ah bah on
personnellement avec système on a été
plusieurs à relire les tonnages les
teneurs les modèles les chercheurs je
peux vous assurer que pour nous en fait
en l'occurrence de toute façon on
s'entend les chercheurs ils ont des
limites ils ont peu de données il y a
relativement peu de données publiques
beaucoup de données qui sont acquises
dans le cadre des plans d'exploration
sont des données confidentielles par
principe puisque ce sont des données qui
sont acquises par des acteurs privés ou
mieux elles sont remises au gouvernant
donc aux États concernés donc de fait
effectivement on n'a pas beaucoup de
données des chercheurs ils font ce
qu'ils peuvent je veux dire moi j'ai pas
envie de cracher sur un tel ou sur un
tel et d'autant qu'ils prennent un
certain nombre de précautions donc c'est
ça le problème la problématique ne vient
pas de là la problématique elle vient du
glissement entre ces évaluations
hypothétiques avec ce qu'on a comme on
fait comme on peut
et
ça représente 140 ans de cobaltes
on sait pas comment exploiter on a des
difficultés majeures pour pouvoir
assurer l'approvisionnement énergétique
on est à des milliers de kilomètres des
côtes on ne sait pas traiter on aura
même pas ça se trouve l'énergie
nécessaire pour assurer le traitement de
ces minerais afin d'obtenir du métal et
j'en passe et j'en passe des difficultés
[Rires]
2035 les voitures thermiques c'est
terminé on a entendu quand même nos
constructeurs surtout nos PDG de
construction de la voiture
tousser un petit peu là quand je vous
entends
ils font des plans sur la comète avec
des ressources hypothétiques avec des
fonds
de ne pas assez donne encore beaucoup
une mine qui ouvre ça dure combien de
temps la dépression de la mine ça arrive
au bout de combien d'années selon le
type de métaux nomInes sont en bonne
santé ce qu'on a prévu de réouvrir des
mines en France ailleurs en Europe je
vois plein de petits projets en Europe
plein de petits points sur la carte de
projet minier lapin un seul en France
c'est pourquoi c'est parce que les
Français ont dit on va pas faire de mine
comment ça se passe
alors par rapport à ça la première chose
qu'il faut avoir en tête déjà c'est sur
la question de la santé des mines dans
le monde
encore une fois moi je suis pas analyste
mignonne donc c'est à dire que je n'ai
pas connaissance de tous les dizaines de
milliers de sites miniers et dans le
monde en fonctionnement et en projet pas
du tout j'ai pas du tout cette
connaissance ce que je peux vous en dire
par contre c'est que effectivement il y
a une explosion du nom de cirque
effectivement il y a un certain nombre
de sites mini actuellement qui
exploitent
il y a une explosion du nombre de
projets qui est effectivement lié
clairement là il y a pas de doute c'est
lié au développement des plans que vous
décriviez et là il y a pas de doute il y
a un lien direct entre les plans qui
sont annoncés et la nécessité de
développer des nouveaux gisements
et du coup donc ça vraiment oui ça je le
confirme alors après
ce que l'on peut dire on constate que
sur les très très gros gisements moi qui
suis un certain nombre d'activités sur
des très gros sites que je suis depuis
des années et des années ce qui est
constaté aujourd'hui c'est que les
miniers présentent que ça va être de
plus en plus compliqué d'ouvrir des
nouveaux sites milliers à cause des
écologistes encore alors il y a pas que
les écologistes qui sont en cause
effectivement il y a d'abord et avant
tout les populations locales il y a
aussi autochtone et local qu'elle soit
octonaute en toute priorité il y a
effectivement comme je disais les états
avec des politiques qui sont très
différentes il faut pas croire en fait
que tous les états alors bien sûr les
États en général les gouvernants sont
plutôt en soutien à l'activité minière
c'est assez classique quel que soit les
pays du monde en général les outils les
États sont en soutien de l'industrie
minière et des projets ça c'est une
réalité c'est un fait mais il faut pas
croire que c'est pareil partout déjà et
puis on peut tout à fait s'attendre à ce
qu'à défaut d'abandon de projets on
puisse tendre en fait vers des projets
avec des clauses ou des critères de mise
en exploitation plus contraignantes qui
du coup rendrait plus difficile la mise
en exploitation quand Macron dit la
France est riche en lithium
on ouvre une mine de lithium en France
c'est bien c'est pas bien pour notre
compétitivité pour notre transition pour
les bébés phoques pour
vous
les bébés
alors je finirai sur votre question
d'avant sur mais j'en ai quatre en
stand-by j'espère pouvoir les récupérer
[Rires]
donc les quatre questions précédentes
donc du coup pour commencer par rapport
à celle donc par rapport à la question
du lithium c'est bien ou c'est pas bien
déjà il faut savoir que 6 texte en fait
a pas étudié de façon approfondie la
situation du lithium on a été très
interpellé lorsque l'annonce a été faite
de l'ouverture enfin la poursuite du
gisement dans l'Allier donc pour à
l'horizon alors je sais plus c'est 2025
ou 2026
pour la mise en exploitation pour la
valorisation du lithium donc ça du coup
nous on n'a pas du tout étudié ce
dossier on a absolument rien à dire ni
du bien ni du mal parce que on n'a pas
du tout étudié le dossier j'en sais rien
je ne connais pas la géologie de cette
raison je ne connais pas ce qu'on
appelle la paragineste donc la géologie
j'ai pas d'infos donc ça c'est un
premier point par contre en fait la
problématique je la enfin je la lirai à
d'autres problématiques du coup qui est
palier en fait si vous je ne lirai pas
ça au fait de dire est-ce que c'est bien
est-ce que c'est pas bien le lithium en
France ou quoi que ce soit en fait je le
mettrai dans une problématique plus
générale de du boominier qu'on observe
alors en Europe certes mais partout dans
le monde alors par contre on observe en
Europe ça c'est c'est en fait vous avez
mentionné la France mais de fait il y a
de nombreux pays on peut parler
effectivement de la Serbie pour du
lithium et d'autres nous en mai 2022
avec 6 textes on est parti pendant
plusieurs jours en Andalousie les projet
tous comme des champignons dans cette
zone entre le cuivre le fer voilà le
zinc etc
ensuite du coup on a l'intention de
partir en Suède donc effectivement on va
aller voir ce qui se passe en Suède qui
est un très grand pays mignon européen
et qui fait lui aussi l'objet de moult
convoitise notamment avec le gisement de
fer de Kiruna qui a récemment fait une
annonce de découverte d'un important à
ma minéralisée à terre rare donc sous le
gisement ferry fer donc bref donc tout
ça pour dire qu'effectivement il y a un
empressement moi si vous voulez je suis
pas en train de dire alors il y a
plusieurs choses quand on dit c'est je
vois ce que tout en votre question en
disant est-ce que c'est bien ou est-ce
que c'est pas bien sous-entendu aussi
vous me dites si c'est ce que vous
entendiez c'est vaut mieux le faire chez
nous qu'ailleurs ou dans des pays où la
gouvernance serait faible ou les
conditions environnementales seraient
moindres tout à fait c'est ce que vous
vous sentiez aussi alors
qui sont sales qui font des gros trous
ça dégueule de partout ils ont des
rivières qui changent de couleur avec
des poissons qui nagent avec la tête en
bas des choses comme ça sur le côté
aussi et il y a des pays qui se
prétendent propres c'est à dire qu'ils
exportent
externalisent leur pollution comme ça
ils disent ouais nous on produit super
bien c'est super propre regardez on a
des problèmes aussi de poissons qui
nagent sur le côté alors effectivement
ça c'est un argument fort pour la
l'argumentaire selon lequel il faut
relocaliser l'accès minière en France ou
en Europe c'est un argument qui est un
argument massue qui est utilisé pareil
en disant écoutez nous sommes des pays
d'IS développés nous avons profité de
l'externalisation des impacts de la mine
dans des pays alors soit faible
gouvernance soit avec des
réglementations qui étaient beaucoup
plus on va dire laxiste que chez nous
voilà des gens corrompus aussi allons-y
hein parce que c'est vrai que dans les
pays dit occidentalisés ou dit aux
développer et absolument pas de problème
de corruption c'est connu
d'accord donc du coup effectivement
donc ça c'est une vraie question alors
déjà est-ce que on sait où se passe
l'activité minière déjà à en dire faut
pas que ça se passe là où ça se passe
est-ce qu'on sait
bons
on a cherché en 1970 nos ressources non
les ressources en gros ce que je peux
vous en dire moi c'est que je remercie
des chercheurs incroyables mouth et tal
alors je dis mouse mais c'est je sais
pas si on dit mouse mahus désolé pour la
prononciation maouse s'étale 2022
premier à base de données des zones en
exploitation à petit et à grande échelle
minière à l'échelle internationale
publiée en créatif common 4.0 le rêve le
rêve pour les gens comme si ce texte le
rêve absolu quoi enfin du créatif commun
soit on en a marre des données privées
qui coûtent la peau des fesses et j'en
parle parce que je fais beaucoup
beaucoup de travail de recherche et que
je pleure beaucoup beaucoup devant des
rapports qui coûtent des milliers des
bases de données qui coûte 15 à 20 000
dollars par an je ferme la parenthèse et
donc en l'occurrence donc incroyable et
on se retrouve en fait donc c'est des
chercheurs en fait
c'est l'impression que je diverge mais
pas du tout vous allez vraiment vous
allez voir où je vais en venir donc en
fait c'est des chercheurs qui ont pris
donc à partir d'une base de données qui
est assez connue de SP global des points
sur les cartes du monde où il y a sur
une carte du monde en fait où il y avait
des sites milliers en exploitation à
petit et à grande échelle et en fait à
partir de ces points ils ont rajouté un
travail de reconnaissance à partir d'une
analyse fine d'image satellitaire donc
ce qui fait que peu importe les données
qu'annoncent les pays puisque là on est
sur le satellite donc c'est de du
satellite mondial et c'est cette
corrélation des deux qui a permis en
fait de faire des contourages voyez de
faire des polygones autour des zones en
exploitation donc minassielle ouvert les
zones de dépôt de déchets parce qu'on
les sous-estime souvent alors que c'est
majeur dans l'empreinte minière les
installations minières et l'ensemble des
installations nécessaires au
fonctionnement des sites milliers à la
fin ce travail de titan qu'ils ont fait
obtiennent 45 000 polygones 45000
polygones pour une surface d'environ
102000 km². 1000 km², si on sait pas
trop ce que ça veut faire la France de
mémoire c'est 550 000 km2 donc c'est un
cinquième de la France quoi voilà la
surface ils expliquent que c'est pas
exhaustif mais en tous les cas c'est un
premier premier pas vers une
cartographie voilà donc c'est uniquement
les zones d'attention en exploitation ça
ne comprend ni les sites faire mais ni
les sites en projet et ça comprend et le
petit échelle et le grand échelle et ben
maintenant on va regarder les pays donc
du coup ça nous donne cette carte elle
est géniale parce qu'elle nous dit où
est-ce que se passe l'activité minière
actuellement enfin à date des images
satellites donc de mémoire 2019 on est
d'accord donc assez récent tout de même
où est-ce que se passe l'activité Mia en
Chine alors vous allez dire quoi du coup
et trois premiers pays du monde
Argentine vous êtes vous êtes dans les
13 premiers
alors moi j'ai dit optimiser un moyen
mnémotechnique je vais vous les donner
dans l'ordre j'ai d'utiliser un moyen
homothétique sinon je m'en souviendrai
pas donc je vais vous donner dans
l'ordre dans des pays donc d'accord mais
en termes d'emprise
donc on est d'accord c'est l'emprise des
installations minières ça vous dit là où
il y a la plus grande surface d'activité
minière
non Russie donc c'est RCA EIB Russie
Chine Australie et États-Unis Indonésie
Brésil
Russie Chine Australie États-Unis
Indonésie Brésil c'est 6 pays là il
représente 52% de la surface mondiale
puis en plus on est fâché avec le
premier
transition écologique énergétique ça va
être compliqué
ça c'est les six premiers 52%
ensuite CCA paga désolé pour le moyen
mnémote j'en ai besoin
Canada Chili Afrique du Sud pagaie Pérou
Guyana
Argentine Inde
donc je répète Canada
Chili Afrique du Sud Pérou Guyana
Argentine Inde
ça c'est donc cette pays c'est sept pays
font les 23% supplémentaires à eux seuls
donc dans 75 75% de l'emprise en ottante
on parle que d'emprise minière se
déroule dans 13 pays dont des pays ou
combien connu comme étant des pays avec
un indice de développement extrêmement
faible j'ai nommé l'Australie le Canada
les États-Unis
n'est pas un pays développé
non mais voilà
la Chine c'est des grands pays le Brésil
l'Inde c'est des très grands pays c'est
des grands pays industrialisés vous
voyez je vous ai mentionné qu'un seul
pays du continent africain et pas
n'importe lequel l'Afrique du Sud ça
c'est pour 75% des surfaces et après
effectivement il vous manque 24% dans 61
pays et 1% dans 71 pays donc vous voyez
c'est très très concentré l'activité
minière en fait donc si vous voulez moi
j'ai quand même des gens qui viennent me
voir pour me dire la problématique de
votre discours quand vous dénoncez les
ravages de la distribution parce que on
s'entend un système ne travaille que sur
l'in finir donc c'est les activités
industrielles n'ont pas les activités à
petite échelle est-ce que vous
travaillez sur le côté bénéfique qu'ils
apportent à la société
lequel
par exemple
les climatiseurs
oui on travaille sur le côté bénéfique
puisqu'on travaille sur l'utilisation
des métaux dans les produits en fin de
c'est important la question économique
il est question sociale elles ont été
traitées par Babington étal Owen et camp
babyton et Babington 2018 vous avez
pléthore de publication Campbell comme
belle 2010 Campbell 2013 commence 2012
Arte commence 2014 je peux vous fournir
une liste
infinie de publication qui remettent en
cause le bienfait social et économique
et économique des projets miniers donc
effectivement il faut plus s'intéresser
à ce qu'il produisent pour voir quelque
chose parce que économiquement et
socialement parlant c'est la catastrophe
vraiment
l'électricité on en reparlera de ça
juste après
je sais pas et on va on va en reparler
juste après parce que ça c'est ça va
être très très important
c'est extrêmement important mais j'ai
pas parlé de l'industrie minière je
parle d'un modèle sur lequel repose
l'industrie minière et là il y a une
grande différence il y a la grande
différence c'est à dire que moi je parle
du modèle si je dis aujourd'hui
l'industrie minière telle qu'elle est
menée le modèle sur lequel elle repose
conduisent à des externalités
environnementales sociales et humaine
qui sont gravissimes et la problématique
c'est que ça s'aggrave l'investissement
qui investit des actions que des actions
dans un dans un une compagnie minière
qui lui donne un rendement
extraordinaire pour payer ses
fonctionnaires à la retraite
alors soit ils sont aveugles soit ils
sont sourds tous les cas ils sont pas
mauvais ça on en est sûr mais ils sont
soitveugles soit sourds la plupart des
compagnies minières dans lesquelles ils
ont investissent ont des externalités
des impacts extrêmement graves voire
même ils sont courants l'une des
publications que j'ai mentionnées tout à
l'heure c'est commence 2012 Catherine
koumance elle a fait un travail
incroyable sur la mine de Marlyn mine
d'or au Guatemala depuis le début les
gens ont dit non ils ont dit on ne veut
pas de ce projet les gens ont forcé
absolument pour que le projet se fasse
les industriels ont forcé les
gouvernants des représentants canadiens
sont venus pour faire en sorte que le
projet toute cette publication est dédié
à ce projet là cette situation et en
plus pour ça que je vous en parle on est
allé chercher du coup des groupes
composés multipartites composés
d'industriels miniers et d'investisseurs
dit investisseurs responsable pour aller
soutenir le fait que l'entreprise
minière maintenait bon gré malgré son
activité malgré le refus malgré des
faits référendums malgré des alertes
internationales de la part de la
communauté internationale nombreuse donc
je reviens sur cette histoire là après
sur justement et ça va être là le un
point qui va être majeur sur la conduite
des projets miniers donc quand vous me
posiez la question tout à l'heure en me
disant effectivement il y a cette
question d'externalisation alors déjà au
regard de la liste que je vous ai fourni
on peut légèrement je crois pondérer
l'idée selon laquelle si c'est pas fait
en France c'est fait au Togo puisqu'en
fait le Togo ne fait pas partie de la
liste que je vous ai fourni par exemple
voilà c'est-à-dire qu'en fait en
l'occurrence ce sont des très sans payer
industriels pour la plupart d'entre eux
qui ont une très bonne maîtrise minière
j'oserais peut-être même dire qu'ils ont
peut-être même des compétences qui sont
supérieures aux autres pour conduire les
projets miniers je pense que les
Australiens en l'occurrence par exemple
souvent qui est beaucoup de contacts au
Canada souvent les gens ils me disent oh
les Australiens ils sont toujours à
montrer qu'ils savent ils ont une avance
sur nous sur des techniques ou sur des
façons de procéder donc voilà clairement
je veux dire clairement il y a quand
même des États qui sont extrêmement
forts dans cette liste là et qui sont en
fait les représentants de là où se
déroulent aujourd'hui la mine donc ça
c'est à quelque chose qu'il faut avoir
déjà en tête ensuite par rapport à la
question que vous posiez la
problématique en fait n'est pas de
est-ce que c'est bien quand monsieur
Macron ou un tout autre représentant
d’état en fait nous dit bah tiens c'est
bien on va faire de la mine dans un
autre pays en fait la question qu'il
faut lui poser c'est pourquoi
pour la transition écologique et
énergétique il faut être beaucoup plus
précis que ça il faut
être beaucoup plus précis que ça ça ne
suffit pas c'est à dire que les chiffres
qui ont été annoncés notamment pour la
mine de lithium en Allier en
l'occurrence donc le chiffre en terme de
quantité de batterie que cela pourrait
représenter ces chiffres en fait qu'il
faut à ce moment-là si on me dit qu'on
veut par exemple faire je sais pas 75000
batteries ou 100000 batteries derrière
en fait il faut qu'on m'explique
pourquoi est-ce que les autres options
étaient étudiées notamment on a beaucoup
parlé avec vous de la question du
véhicule électrique c'est à dire est-ce
que vous avez mis remis en cause un
quelconque moment dans votre discours la
mobilité individuelle est-ce que c'est
est-ce que ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
a posé sur la table est-ce que à un
moment donné on s'est dit le véhicule
électrique est extrêmement efficace
schématiquement dans des zones urbaines
pour du transport léger dans des petits
véhicules pour du transport lé et de
petites distances c'est pour ça qu'il a
un intérêt ce véhicule en toute priorité
est-ce que on a établi des scénarios où
on
privilégait l'usage majeur l'usage le
plus intéressant de ce véhicule avec par
exemple un mix je ne sais pas un mix de
véhicule est-ce que on a mis en place
des politiques de transport collectif
puisque je fais partie des gens je suis
désolé mais qui remettent fortement en
cause la validité et la viabilité
énergétique de la mobilité individuelle
non non non on met un scénario on dit on
prend tout le pack automobile on fait en
sorte que tout le monde puisse aller
d'un point à un point B à n'importe quel
moment du jour ou de la nuit avant qu'on
en dépensant des quantités d'énergie
phénoménales et on fait prends tout ça
translation électrique et jeunesse mais
ça en fait moi comme je ne crois pas en
ce scénario là je ne peux décemment donc
pas comprendre pourquoi on exploite du
métal pour répondre à ça c'est à dire
que en fait moi je j'adhère à n'importe
quel projet minier je le dis si ce texte
serait d'accord avec moi à partir du
moment ou en face on a des gens qui
viennent papier crayon en main et qui
nous explique voilà aujourd'hui la
stratégie c'est ça pour le secteur de la
santé ça pour le secteur de l'éducation
ça pour le secteur du transport
collectif ça pour le secteur des
énergies renouvelables ne les oublions
pas ce n'est pas parce que les pauvres
elles consomment beaucoup de métaux que
il faut leur jeter le propre non plus ça
va 5 minutes donc voilà j'ai besoin de
ça parce que ça c'est impératif et ça
c'est donc on a besoin j'ai une pleine
conscience que les scénarios métalliques
que j'entretiens depuis 70 années sont
complètement insoutenables que les taux
de croissance sont infolents et que du
coup rassurez-vous madame Stéphan sistex
les citoyens français j'ai bien sûr un
plan drastique de diminution métallique
c'est-à-dire que là ce que je suis en
train de vous présenter c'est la demande
métallique complémentaire dont j'ai
besoin pour assurer les services dont on
a tous besoin en priorité santé
éducation alimentation accès à l'eau
potable et une fois que ça c'est fait
après avoir bien sûr réduit j'ai obtenu
beaucoup à peu près parce que c'est
toujours difficile de connaître une
quantité exacte de métaux et pour ça en
fait je voudrais conduire un projet
minier parce que entre temps aussi j'ai
dépensé des millions d'euros dans des
plans forts de recyclage que j'ai mis
tout ce que je pouvais pour obtenir la
plus petite parcelle de métaux que j'ai
mis aussi en place des programmes qui me
permet de concevoir des dispositifs qui
sont recyclables et sachez madame
Stéphane d'ailleurs que j'ai sanctionné
durement tous les concepteurs qui
produisent des produits qui ne sont pas
recyclables là oui je dis projet minier
quand tu veux
là oui tant que ce programme là il aura
pas été fait ce n'est pas la peine de
venir me voir et de me dire il faut
continuer alors je sais que de toute
façon ça continue on le sait on le voit
de toute façon vu les quantités qu'il y
a j'ai pas demandé demain l'arrêt des
mines de toute façon si c'est que c'est
pas en timide et voilà dedans on est pas
du tout là-dedans on est en train
d'essayer de raisonner quelque chose qui
est complètement déraisonnable c'est ça
la problématique
pour les politiques en fait
pourquoi plus pour les politiques
ce qui est sûr c'est que la prospective
oui ils sont toujours affûtés sur leur
perspective
ce qui est sûr c'est que là alors
comme beaucoup d'auteurs d'ailleurs dans
que j'ai lu dans la sociologie ce qu'on
dénonce c'est le manque de contrôle par
les États des activités minières dans
tous les sens en fait c'est-à-dire qu'il
y a une en fait ce n'est pas au secteur
minier de décider oui il y a un service
à produire il doit produire du métal ce
n'est pas à lui de décider les
trajectoires industriels qui doivent
être prises par des états et ça c'est
très important c'est-à-dire que je
dirais chacun ses prérogatives d'accord
les mini safèrent de la mine les
gouvernants sont censés savoir faire de
la gouvernance étatique
les masques ils ont rien prévu ils ont
fait des petites affichettes à 4
donc effectivement ce qui est sûr c'est
que voilà pour pour moi c'est chacun
doit avoir son rôle et la problématique
en fait c'est que ce que nous constatons
est encore une fois je me repose sur un
certain nombre de chercheurs en
sociologie je vous en ai mentionné
quelques-uns qui sont assez connus comme
babyton ou au frais Babington c'est des
noms qui pour ceux qui s'intéressent aux
impacts de la mine reviennent souvent
c'est qu'effectivement il y a une
problématique en fait c'est le manque de
prise en main de la question minière et
métallique par les États c'est un sujet
en soi je peux vous couper j'avais feu
un grand copain qui a envoyé des ballons
sur Vénus et un jour on a une grande
discussion sur Elon Musk et il me disait
elyun musk c'est un commercial
extraordinaire pour motiver les gens à
aller dans l'espace il met des des
petits mannequins il envoie sa voiture
en l'air parce que ça fait toujours
vibrer les gens de voir ils peuvent se
projeter du fait qu'ils vont aller dans
l'espace mais en fait son objectif c'est
pas du tout de les coloniser mars
c'est de mettre des astéroïdes en orbite
autour de la Terre et d'exploiter les
ressources minières de ces astéroïdes
alors peut-être que mon pote se trompait
à l'époque est-ce que vous avez entendu
parler de ça de la mise en orbitation
d'astéroïdes pour l'exploitation minière
le fait qu'on vous dites mises en
orbitation vous dites il faut modifier
la trajectoire des astéroïdes pour que
on soit plus en capacité de les suivre
c'est ça que vous dites
plus facilement
comme on disait la dernière fois en fait
effectivement nous on en a rapidement
entendu parler il y a bien des projets
en tous les cas d'exploitation
spatiale qui sont en cours d'études ça
c'est vous avez là-dessus vous avez
raison la problématique en fait alors
j'ai eu de la chance parce que j'ai eu
la chance de discuter avec une personne
qui travaille de très près dans ce dans
ce
qui travaille au cœur de ces sujets là
et en plus qui m'avait contacté en
disant bah si vous voulez des infos moi
je travaille sur ces questions là dans
le domaine spatial et je vous ai vu à
thinkerview puis vous disais que vous en
saviez rien donc si vous voulez je peux
vous aider et j'ai donc eu la chance
d'avoir presque 3 heures de discussion
avec lui et donc c'était passionnant et
en l'occurrence en fait il m'indiquait à
très juste titre ce que j'avais un tout
petit peu annoncé lors de notre dernière
interview c'est en fait plutôt la
problématique en fait de de ramener le
matériel en fait tu sais il disait la
plupart du temps quand on fait il
m'expliquait quand on fait des mises en
orbite de matériel type satellites ou
autres et bien en l'occurrence en fait
on a souvent on les laisse en orbite et
c'est pour ça qu'on se retrouve avec des
quantités incroyables de déchets parce
que en fait ça demande trop d'énergie et
trop d'efforts pour ramener le matériel
donc il me disait autant en fait déposer
un objet et éventuellement sur un objet
en orbite ce serait tout à fait
envisageable enfin tout à fait
envisageable attention un non option à
certains nombre de considérations 100
ans mais par contre en fait la
problématique qui va probablement rester
insoluble ou difficilement
résolvable ça va être la capacité de
ramener le matériel c'est à dire à la
fois de se poser de creuser puis après
de ramener le matériel et ni et de fait
si on laisse autant d'objets dans
l'espace parce que ça demande trop
d'énergie de les ramener sur terre et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on les laisse en
orbite c'est pas pour entre guillemets
faire deux fois pire d'une certaine
façon avec des tonnages beaucoup plus
importants dans le cas d'une
exploitation éventuelle voilà ce que je
peux vous en dire adapté donc ça paraît
très compromis au regard de l'énergie
nécessaire pour repartir en fait sur la
terre une fois que c'est mis en orbite
donc voilà et donc tout ça pour dire
qu'effectivement voilà sur les plans que
vous disiez moi il y a cet enjeu là de
dire en fait une fois qu'on aura
travaillé vraiment comme je vous disais
en fait on a pris à bras le corps le
scénario dans son ensemble c'est à dire
bien réfléchir aux usages mais aux
usages lorsqu'ils sont le plus adaptés
ne pas hésiter à remettre en cause comme
on disait un véhicule électrique c'est
un usage en particulier qui est
intéressant le valoriser lui en priorité
et puis éventuellement envisager des
mixes ou des adaptations donc il y a
voilà c'est réfléchir aux usages en
priorité et mettre en place tout ce qui
est possible avant en fait c'est à dire
que la problématique c'est que il y a un
certain nombre de dommages que on ne
sera pas en mesure de réparer et là
j'insiste en fait on parle pas juste en
fait vous voyez là on est tranquillement
dans une pièce et on peut effectivement
refaire le monde mais derrière en fait
il y a des gens nous quand on était
quand on était en Andalousie en mai 2022
on a rencontré des gens qui sont dans
une situation qui est catastrophique
pour des projets miniers qui datent de
quelques années seulement c'est on est
sur des situations qui sont humaines qui
sont catastrophiques et du point de vue
environnemental qui sont catastrophiques
si au moins le fait que je sois là ce
soir peut faire porter le message de
tous ces gens qui n'ont jamais droit à
la parole et qui sont dans des
situations mais qui sont catastrophiques
les gens me disent ah bah si ce texte
quand même vous avez une énergie madame
Stéphan parce que et ben vous vous
hésitez pas à parler de ces problèmes
mais c'est parce que leur situation elle
est dramatique c'est dramatique ce qui
est en train de se passer j'espère
pouvoir vous faire passer quoi on voit
on entend on lit on réfléchit on discute
avec des gens qui sont au bout du
rouleau les gens certes on en a parlé
tout à l'heure des victimes de
l'après-midi française en passant par
les villages qui se trouvent en
Andalousie qui sont en train de mourir
sous la contamination et je ne sais trop
pas encore les les pêcheurs qui ne
vivent plus de la pêche et qui sont en
train de dépérir parce qu'on a
complètement pollué leur leur comment
dirais leur zone de pêche que ce soit à
Madagascar allez hop je vais en prendre
un hasard le projet Ford dauphin qui se
trouve à Madagascar projet de diminude
pour du titane ou encore les projets
d'étain en Malaisie en fait où en
Indonésie c'est la catastrophe quoi en
fait c'est que nous on en parle on
chiffre on le met en avant parce qu'il y
a une gravité et le pire
vous allez finir couler dans le béton si
vous continuez comme ça
[Rires]
c'est
que
le ptes plan de transformation de
l'économie française et qu'en
pense-t-elle non je ne l'ai pas lu
je vous laisse continuer d'accord je
n'ai pas lu oui et sachez
qu'effectivement souvent les gens ils
posent vachement de questions sur la
transition les bilans énergétiques et
tout ça donc je rappelle toujours un que
je suis pas énergéticienne je préfère le
rappeler et que du coup en fait il y a
plein plein de questions moi je regarde
plutôt les plans de transition du côté
métallique du côté de la production de
ce que ça représente en terme minier ou
en termes de conséquences sur par
exemple la production minière ou les
modèles en termes de production mais
c'est vrai que je vais moins
m'intéresser je vais moins regarder je
laisse faire des gens qui sont dix fois
plus compétents que moi sur ces sujets
là
est-ce que vous voulez qu'on parle d'un
autre sujet à un sujet qu'on n'a pas
encore traité
oui pour répondre de votre question
parce qu'il y a plein de questions qu'on
a pas avec nous
il y en a un qui me tient car ce que
donc du coup vous avez parlé de l'Europe
et de ce fameux boominier et du coup je
il y en a un qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur parce qu'on a
sorti un gros rapport la semaine
dernière de surf c'est pas parce qu'on a
sorti un gros rapport c'est parce que je
voudrais venir en aide aux gens dont je
vous parle je vous disais la situation
elle est dramatique et si ce texte en
fait depuis à peu près deux ans et
l'année dernière ça c'est vraiment
accéléré
alors certes suite au premier passage à
thinkervie on était plus connu donc de
fait il y a un billet parce qu'on est
plus sollicité parce qu'on est plus
connus mais il y a quand même un gros
différence
vous avez raison de l'appeler comme ça
je peux ouvrir la parenthèse là dessus
dans les semaines dans les jours qu'on
suivit alors moi déjà mon LinkedIn à
saturé du coup LinkedIn a coupé mon
compte ouais parce qu'ils ont il y avait
tellement de connexion moi j'essayais
gentiment ce que je me rendais pas
compte je voyais plein de messages qui
arrivaient alors je répondais aux gens
etc mais il y a plein de demandes de
connexion qui arrive et puis moi j'y
connais rien mais j'y connais rien au
réseau sociaux et du coup à force de
répondre d'envoyer des messages et tout
LinkedIn il a bloqué en disant il y a un
robot qui a piraté votre compte vous
avez beaucoup trop d'activités
vous êtes une illustre inconnue madame
Stefan vous ne devriez pas avoir autant
de monde qui s'intéressent à vous c'est
complètement normal allez hop compte
bloquer du coup bon bah j'ai dû attendre
après le compte c'est machin puis après
bon il y a eu tout un ensemble après du
coup deux semaines après consiste bloqué
énorme trop de messages en fait le
formulaire de contact en fait a
complètement saturé du coup j'ai eu les
boîtes qui saturaient j'ai eu le site
internet qui a eu des bugs du coup j'ai
du réintervenir sur le site internet et
après du coup j'ai eu des milliers de
personnes si ce texte a reçu donc si
c'était indépendamment de de moi mon
LinkedIn qui est ma seule porte d'entrée
ce texte a reçu 2000 messages en 10 mois
2000 messages en 10 mois on les a toutes
traité on a eu 899 demandes demande de
conférence demande de collaboration
demande de d'informations voilà c'est
gigantesque
nous ça a été on n'arrête pas de dire
aux gens nous sommes deux salariés 15
bénévoles et on arrête pas de le dire
mais les gens continuent il faut que
vous fassiez quand même des choses vous
pouvez poser à vos questions du coup on
est on est très embêtés mais on est
ravis on est ravis que
[Rires]
alors oui ah ça c'est un petit peu plus
bas ça c'est plus c'est effectivement
c'est plus ça me concerne plus moi du
coup c'est que effectivement du coup je
suis passé du stade de illustre anonyme
à alors je sais pas ce que je suis une
personne qui est connue un peu
et donc c'est oui c'est
vous saviez il y a pas que les initiés
avec de la bienveillance oui toujours
avec de la bienveillance je suis très
étonnée de
[Musique]
la gentillesse effectivement vous
parliez de bienveillance il y a aussi
beaucoup de gens qui est-ce et
d'amabilité
extraordinaire pour ça et je la remercie
beaucoup et effectivement oui non c'est
ça qui est très compliqué à l'échelle
personnelle en fait c'est d'être très
très sollicité
des gens voilà dans le métro il n'y a
pas plus tard que deux semaines
quelqu'un qui m'a demandé un autographe
en fait je peux pas je peux pas le faire
en fait voilà il y a des il y a des gens
enfin au supermarché on m'a demandé une
photo un selfie dans un rayon de fruits
et légumes et on peut faire ça ah non
mais moi j'aime pas les photos de toute
façon donc l'affaire est donc réglée et
en fait du coup vous voyez en fait ça
c'est un peu on va dire c'est une
échelle qui me dépasse personnellement
complètement même si j'ai énormément de
respect pour les gens qui suivent les
travaux de l'association je suis
vraiment ravie et je les incite à faire
passer le message en fait je suis
vraiment ravie pour ça mais c'est vrai
qu'à l'échelle individuelle oui ça me ça
me dépasse vraiment complètement et puis
bah après voilà ça amène toute
l'ensemble de situation de gens qui vous
interpellent effectivement dans la rue
des gens qui vous reconnaissent alors
que vous êtes en randonnée à l'autre
bout du monde des gens qui apprennent
que vos amis vous connaissent qui du
coup et demandent d'avoir des
rendez-vous avec vous enfin ça commence
à être un peu voilà donc voilà puis bon
bah du coup enfin tout toutes les
sollicitations c'est à dire que je suis
déjà en termes de travail en fait moi le
coeur de mon métier j'ai pas de
Community Manager j'ai pas d'assistant
ou d'assistante tout ce que je fais les
nouvelles les mois qui les envoient mon
planning c'est moi qui le gère avec un
agenda papier j'ai pas tout ça donc ce
qui fait en fait que les énormes
quantités de sollicitations et de
demande c'est extrêmement compliqué à
gérer pour les services de l'État se
sont rapprochés de vous à la suite de
votre passage
alors il y a des représentants
de différents ministères
de plusieurs ministères
de représentants qui ont un rôle
important dans ces ministères et toutes
sortes les ministères auquel on change
pas d'ailleurs au début
un jeune en parlerai pas et du coup en
fait effectivement
qui en fait mon contactait alors ce qui
était chouette aussi c'est des gens qui
ont pu me contacter individuellement
pour me faire part en fait à la fois de
leurs inquiétudes et puis aussi de leur
remerciements vis-à-vis de fait que on
mettait
un coup de projecteur sur ses réalités
qui ont été trop longtemps sous-estimés
dans le débat public donc ça c'était
voilà donc oui il y a des biens des gens
qui ont pris la tâche avec nous des gens
aussi qui ont beaucoup beaucoup de gens
y compris dans des instances
ministérielles ou des instances
publiques ont demandé des formations de
six textes
ou des travaux collaboratifs voilà bon
je suis dans l'incapacité totale de
répondre à toutes ces demandes voilà
enfin c'est pas possible voilà
actuellement là j'ai qu'un j'ai 15000
demandes de connexion en attente sur
Linkedin j'ai 4500 messages sur Linkedin
même si j'en fais 5 et 10 par jour les
pauvres gens ils vont croire que je les
ignore c'est même pas le cas en fait je
les ignore pas du tout c'est fait vous
êtes peut-être au numéro 2800e puis il
m'en reste encore 10 000 à gérer enfin
ça n'a aucun sens vous voyez donc
j'essaye de faire tout ce que je peux
mais pas par contre ce qui est sûr ce
qui était intéressant c'est le panel de
sollicitant c'est à dire que ça va
depuis
dériverains qui sont affectés par des
projets miniers et qui était dans le
désespoir absolu parce qu'il pensait
qu'il y avait aucune association qui
pourrait les aider parce que solliciter
beaucoup de structures associatives et
la plupart n'étant pas spécialisé sur
les questions finalement expliquait
qu'ils étaient pas en mesure de les
aider jusqu'à des représentants
j'ai tout vu quoi enfin je peux vous
donner une liste infinie de de
gouvernement différents de représentants
américains de la Chambre de commerce des
chambres de commerce de représentants
environnementaux enfin voilà c'est
du coup en fait ça ça montre aussi que
ce premier interview sur thinkerview à
la lumière encore une fois de des
centaines de témoignages qu'on a eu ça
montre à quel point cette question elle
était jusqu'à lors sous-estimée ça
montre à quel point il va falloir rattra
jamais le retard par rapport à d'autres
secteurs qui sont beaucoup plus avancés
qui ont des équipes des grosses ONG qui
travaillent exclusivement là-dessus des
experts des groupes de recherche des
recherches etc avec des travaux visibles
c'est à dire que moi vous voyez tout ce
que je vous présente là il y a personne
en France qui s'est intéressé aux
tonnerre et au tonnages des fonds
sous-mains pourtant on a plein de gens
c'est pour ça que vous êtes là
oui mais on peut pas tout faire vous
voyez donc c'est pour ça à dire qu'on
était obligé de verrouiller cette
interview au mois de novembre et qu'on
est obligé de la faire un dimanche parce
que c'est la seule date qui vous restez
dans votre planning et si ça va pas été
pour nous vous seriez restés chez vous
alors au nom de la communauté notre
équipe merci beaucoup d'être venu un
dimanche c'est important revenons
revenons à nos moutons
vous avez pas répondu à quoi déjà vous
voulez parler de quoi je voulais parler
de l'Europe et de la relance en Europe
ce que vous m'avez mentionné
[Rires]
avant de parler de l'in
le premier échelon donc effectivement
par rapport à ça je souhaitais parler de
quelque chose qui est relatif en fait à
la question
de ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
c'était à dire donc indépendamment de ce
qu'on a dit en disant bon faut arrêter
de croire que la mine se déroule
principalement dans des pays pauvres de
l'Asie et de l'Afrique donc une fois que
maintenant on a mis ça de côté d'accord
il y a un autre une autre considération
que j'aimerais avoir que j'aimerais
évoqué avec vous c'est la question du
fait que on soit capable en fait on soit
oui capable de mener des projets de mine
durable ou de mines responsables
pourquoi j'en parle parce que c'est
quelque chose des termes que je vois
très souvent aussi dans la presse voilà
c'est assez régulier puis c'est toutes
les instances ça peut être des instances
gouvernementales enfin étatique ça peut
être des instances européennes qui
parlent le Lamine responsable et de la
mine durable d'ailleurs en mars prochain
la Commission européenne devrait sortir
projet je crois je sais pas exactement
comment ça s'appelle pour définir ce que
serait la mine responsable selon la
Commission européenne ou l'Union
européenne Commission européenne je
crois peu importe et tout ça pour dire
que du coup
donc l'idée en fait c'était de discuter
de ça parce que c'est un vocabulaire qui
est très récurrent
pour parler de quelque chose qui
n'existe pas donc ça m'ennuie qu'on
parle de la mine durable ou de la mine
responsable alors qu'en fait ni l'un ni
l'autre n'existe selon vous
selon moi et les 253 chercheurs que j'ai
étudiés pour le rapport que j'ai publié
la semaine dernière sur notre site
internet
et ça je voudrais vraiment l'évoquer
parce que même c'était une question
d'ailleurs qui nous avait été posée au
1er 5 heures view à la fin déjà ce que
vous estimez qu'une mine responsable
existe et du coup j'étais un petit peu
gênée pour vous répondre parce qu'à
l'époque j'étais pas forte de toutes ces
données là donc j'avais privilégié une
approche un peu différente en terme de
réponse
et du coup en fait je voudrais évoquer
ça ça c'est très important parce que
c'est quelque chose qui est très présent
dans le discours c'est à dire qu'en fait
je sais pas combien de temps on a pour
que je vous explique les choses mais je
vais
dimanche à gauche j'ai un super fan à ma
droite j'ai un super fade
open bar donc en fait
avant donc si on a un peu de temps je
peux vous expliquer déjà ce qu'on entend
aussi beaucoup c'est ce qu'on appelle
les bonnes et les meilleures pratiques
peut-être que vous avez souvent entendu
parler de ça pour ce projet minier ou
pour ce projet rassurez-vous on mettra
en place on mettra en oeuvre les bonnes
et les meilleures pratiques ou encore
rassurez-vous parce que on respecte les
principes de on respecte le standard de
on respecte le guide de peut-être que
c'est des choses qui vous parlent voilà
ça c'est des choses en fait qui sont
voilà c'est des choses très rassurantes
et puis d'ailleurs bonne et meilleure
pratique compte tenu du vocabulaire
choisi on aurait du mal à pas avoir une
bonne appréciation puisque c'est bon et
meilleur en fait faut dire que vu d'où
ils partent c'est forcément meilleur
alors en fait du coup il y a un souci
déjà dans ces bonnes émirates et encore
une fois je vais faire le lien avec la
mine responsable juste après mais déjà
qui change cette dialectique pour sa
témoigne quand même
prise de conscience ça témoigne en tous
les cas d'une prise de conscience de la
nécessité de légitimer l'activité
minière c'est à dire qu'on se rend
compte que l'activité minière est de
plus en plus où les radars et
contrairement aux idées reçues elles
sont plus sous les radars des
organisations internationales que des
associations non gouvernementales
internationales c'est plutôt les
organisations internationales telles que
l'ONU ou autre qui ont plus qui ont plus
encore
qui font encore plus pression d'ailleurs
sur ces questions là donc effectivement
donc vous avez les bonnes et meilleures
pratiques alors je vais définir
quasiment sans ce stricto même s'il y a
pas de définition qui fasse consensus en
tout cas c'est ce que je peux vous dire
de tous les chercheurs qu'on a étudiés
et vous avez bien écouté ce qui est une
bonne pratique et c'est là que on vient
partir du moment où je vous donne la
définition on comprend tout une bonne
pratique donc dans le domaine minier
c'est valable ailleurs mais on va le
donner dans le domaine minier
une manière de conduire une activité à
l'image de ce qui peut raisonnablement
être attendu de la part de
professionnels expérimentés
à l'image de ce qui peut raisonnablement
être attendu de la part de
professionnels
donc en gros c'est ce qu'on pourrait
attendre et en tous les cas c'est
vraiment la définition qui fait foi
de son mieux c'est faire quand on sait
faire c'est ce que on est censé faire
quand on est en fait un industriel de
poids par exemple dans le domaine minier
c'est ce qu'on attend de ce qu'un
industriel de poids contrairement à la
meilleure pratique la meilleure pratique
qui est une manière de conduire une
activité de la façon la plus avancée
possible donc ça rejoint à ce que vous
disiez de la façon la plus avancée
possible dans des conditions techniques
et économiques données
ces deux définitions en fait du coup
quand on nous parle de bonne et
meilleures pratiques mais tous les jours
tous les jours je vois j'entends des
choses en disant l'exploitant a dit
qu'il allait se baser sur des bonnes
meilleurs pratiques l'exploitant a dit
qu'il allait mettre en place des bonnes
les meilleures pratiques etc etc c'est
ces enjeux de bonne et meilleurs
pratiques du coup ça sert énormément un
discours effectivement pour assurer
comme vous disiez c'est rassurant en
fait le problème en fait c'est qu'il
faut pas en attendre plus que ce
squelette que ce que c'est pardon et ce
que c'est ce n'est que ce que je viens
de vous dire c'est très intéressant
cette dialectique parce que ça témoigne
en fait du risque
s'ils ne font pas ce sera pire
effectivement c'est que alors c'est pas
forcément que ce sera pire mais en tous
les cas c'est
ce que Miranda étal en 2005 disait sur
les meilleures pratiques c'est le
minimum d'efforts voir souvent le plus
d'efforts possible car une entreprise
minière peut faire sur un site c'est
plus simple en fait c'est comme ça qu'il
le il le considère en fait et du coup en
fait ça c'est très important d'avoir en
tête parce que souvent du coup quand on
lit ou quand on entend
l'appel a des bonnes et meilleures
pratiques comme étant un espèce de gage
une espèce de garantie d'une conduite
respectueuse voire vertueuse parce que
ça peut aller jusque là d'ailleurs à ce
propos je vous il y a une publication de
La Forest et bertheas
qui a travaillé en fait justement sur ce
qu'on appelle les meilleures techniques
disponibles c'est un type de meilleure
pratique et les techniques propres donc
vous voyez il y a vraiment une
dialectique importante là-dedans ça n'a
rien à voir en fait ça n'a absolument
rien à voir donc il ne faut pas attendre
de ses pratiques que ça puisse soit
révolutionner soit changer quoi que ce
soit j'en tiens pour preuve la France a
émis dans donc la France a
sous le patronage sous la direction du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
il y a une collection qui est sortie en
France en 2007 qui s'appelle la
collection la mine en France qui
contiennent un certain nombre de tomes
sur la mine qui est en fait issue d'un
groupe de travail dit sur la mine
responsable qui avait été mis en place
en 2015 cet ensemble cette collection la
mine en France en fait elle a plusieurs
tomes il y a un tome le tome 12 qui est
consacré à un recueil de bonnes
pratiques dans la mine française alors
dans la mine c'est un bonne pratique
pour vous donner un exemple il y a 174
bonnes pratiques donc moi on a dit super
on a un recueil de bonnes pratiques en
plus c'est en France à être facile on a
on a les la pratique française soit dans
la mine quoi super on va aller le
regarder il y a 174 pratique on les a
toutes regardées une par une toutes les
174 pratique ensuite on les a trié
sachant que du coup les auteurs vous
disent on a une partie c'est ce qu'ils
appellent des exigences réglementaires
bon du coup selon les comptes quoi enfin
elles sont dedans mais bon elles ont pas
trop d'intérêt puisque de fait une bonne
pratique on s'attend quand même qu'ils
aillent au delà de la réglementation
après vous avez les réglementaires
bonifiés je vous avouerai qu'on a
toujours pas vraiment compris on a relu
plusieurs fois mais on sait pas
exactement ce qui sous-tendu avec le
temps
bonifier et ensuite vous avez donc ce
qu'ils appellent les bonnes pratiques en
tant que tel alors sachant que nous à
l'intérieur à chaque fois qu'il y avait
écrit informé
faire part des résultats communiquer les
résultats etc nous on a considéré que
c'était pas vraiment des bonnes
pratiques parce que bon enfin informé
heureusement qu'on informe merci donc on
les a mises de côté il faut se mettre à
leur place aussi avant ils informaient
pas
donc maintenant c'est une bonne pratique
vous êtes vous êtes dans le vrai donc du
coup
je cherche pas la petite bête
j'essaye de savoir ce que c'est qu'une
bonne pratique en France voilà
effectivement et donc du coup sur les
sens 74 pratique il y en a déjà du coup
plus que 70
bon nous déjà ça fait plus 44% si on
enlève les règlementsaires les
réglementaires bonifiés et celles qui
relève de l'information et de la
communication c'est pas grave on va se
concentrer là dessus et alors du coup ce
qui est et ce qui est valable pour ce
cas là je vous donne parce que c'est un
cas français et du coup on aurait pu
peut-être qu'on aurait oui moi je pense
oui je vais dire tel que je le pense
j'espérais mieux effectivement de mon
pays encore une fois et du coup bon
voilà comme ça c'est dit et en
l'occurrence du coup bref donc sur ces
44 % qui me restent en fait du coup mes
77 pratiques j'en ai gardé mais en fait
c'est pour vous montrer que parfois
c'est les bonnes pratiques c'est
vraiment enfin je suis obligée de rire
parce que c'est vraiment élémentaire
j'ai un peu honte de vous le dire mais
je vais vous la dire alors de mémoire je
vais essayer de vous la citer au plus
près de ce qui écrit en termes de bonnes
pratiques c'est
prévenir préalablement et informer les
propriétaires des parcelles concernées
par les travaux d'exploration
[Rires]
moi je veux bien faire des efforts
je peux comprendre qu'il y a une inertie
dans les innovations technologiques et
techniques dans le domaine minier je
peux comprendre que ce soit des grosses
machines que ce soit difficile de les
faire changer la première chose quand
vous lisez ça en termes de bonnes
pratiques vous savez ce qu'on réagit on
dit mais encore heureux je vais pas
aller chez monsieur et madame je sais
pas qui arrivait avec ma foireuse en
disant je fais des travaux d'exploration
encore heureux qu'on informe
préalablement enfin qu'on prenne contact
préalablement avec les auteurs ça c'est
une bonne pratique dans le recueil des
bonnes pratiques de la mine française
quand même où vous avez aussi prendre
connaissance horloge pourrait plus vous
le citez mot pour mot mais c'est prendre
connaissance
des autres activités qui se tiennent sur
le territoire au moment des travaux
d'exploitation quoi
oui ce serait bien de ça s'il y a
d'autres activités qui se tiennent là on
va mener un projet minier on s'entend
oui encore heureux voilà et vous avez
aussi ce type de déclaration c'est parce
qu'on se dirige vers une économie de
guerre alors soit de guerre vis-à-vis de
la Russie soit de guerre vis-à-vis du
réchauffement climatique et que on met
quand même l'effort de ça va être chaud
il va être obligé de faire des trous
partout pour essayer de trouver des
métaux de la technologie pour soit
résister à des bombardements soit faire
des armes soit envoyer des armes soit
résister un réchauffement climatique et
des choses comme ça est-ce que vous
sentez
c'est tellement chaud que ils essayent
quand même de mettre les formes c'est
Bruno Le Maire il aime beaucoup mettre
les formes dans tout et il prévient que
bon bah on va venir chez toi on va te
prévenir on va faire plein de trous
partout donc mais on va te prévenir si
il faut mettre l'effort moi j'ai pas de
problème mais par contre j'appelle à une
honnête quoi moi ça me pose pas de
problème en soi même enfin je veux dire
qu'on vienne
tellement un bain de sang que vous
pensez pas qu'ils vont paniquer enfin en
tous les cas
je sais pas personnellement je pense que
vous augmentez le niveau
d'incompréhension et tension beaucoup
plus
si vous vous éloignez considérablement
des attentes sociétales en dissimulant
derrière des discours qui sont
rassurants la réalité ça fait des années
qu'on essaie d'avoir cette attitude face
à eux les gens sont justes
pour leur expliquer non je parle pas des
milliers je parle de gouvernement
en fait là pour le coup pour le si on
prend l'exemple des bonnes et meilleures
pratiques imaginez-vous en fait quand
vous essayez de faire des efforts vous
dites moi je vais vraiment essayer
d'étudier les projets miniers je vais
voir en fait ce que les gens font que
vous regardez les bonnes pratiques qu'on
vous dit enfin là je vous ai donné le
cas français mais attendez je peux vous
raconter le cas de la SCM j'ouvre une
parenthèse mais elle est géniale
celle-là les principes de la CM vous
voyez que c'est la SCMM
en disant réellement réellement en
améliorant réellement les questions
sanitaires humaines environnementales
sociales de mes sites et voyez c'est
comme ça que c'est présenté c'est voilà
c'est vraiment voilà les principes de
l'ASM c'est principal indépendamment de
tout ce qu'on pourrait dire sur les
initiatives et volontaires telles que
les principes et lignes directrices
comme ça qui ne valent rien du tout mais
indépendamment le texte le texte prenait
le texte droit humain attendent de
performance 3.4 respecter les droits des
travailleurs de points
ah oui en ne recouvrant pas au travail
des enfants
ni au travail forcé Point Virgule en
évitant
la traite des êtres humains Point
Virgule en ne confiant pas de tâches
dangereuses et risquées risqués et
dangereuse à des personnes de moins de
18 ans bon après la tente de performance
se poursuit
je vais dire quand vous lisez ça
pourquoi je vous en parle de cet exemple
là parce que quelqu'un qui a envie
vraiment que on aille vers le bon sens
enfin qu'on aille vers le vrai quoi
qu'on essaye de sortir de cette
situation terrible qui arrive il y en a
il y en a plein qui arrivent sur des
principes comme ça et pense vraiment que
c'est du solide ils arrivent là dessus
encore heureux que vous souhaitiez
éviter la traite des êtres humains
excusez-moi du peu tout de même enfin
bon je suis désolé enfin vous n'êtes pas
foulé là quand même merci
que les 8 documents de positionnement
associés c'est vide les exigences sont
extrêmement faibles c'est vide enfin
c'est vide
leur proposer de muscler un petit peu
leur
leur charte
la raison pour laquelle on leur propose
pas de muscler leur charte c'est que si
sexe donc à travailler pendant hors deux
ans pas en continu mais pendant deux ans
qu'il a très en continu ces derniers
mois pour sortir le dernier rapport sur
les bonnes pratiques que je vous ai
décrite les meilleures pratiques et le
constat que je viens de faire est à peu
près le même pour les tout ce qu'on
appelle ça les standards les standards
les codes de bonne conduite les normes
les principes les lignes directrices les
index enfin voyez tout ça là ce truc là
on a fait une étude énorme là-dessus
aussi et force cette constater que tous
les auteurs s'accordent quand même à
globalement même s'il y a des
différences mais tous les auteurs
s'accordent quand même sur le fait de
dire c'est pas efficace ça n'a pas
conduit à l'amélioration
en tous les cas pas les chats
sectorielles peut-être des actions
ponctuelles et donc en l'occurrence en
fait cette étude nous qu'on a mené je
vous raconte pas en étudiait 75
initiatives c'est c'était long c'était
long on a fait une base de données de 75
initiatives des principes des stands à
75 75 sachez qu'il y a certains auteurs
qui ont référence 158 initiatives 158
initiatives dont peuvent relever
potentiellement un industrielmi et 158
que vous voulez vous faire avec ça je
ferme la parenthèse tout ça pour dire
que nous on a étudié 75 je vous fais le
résumé du rapport en disant à la fin
ce qu'on a compris c'est que c'était
intrinsèquement pas dimensionné pour
prendre en charge les problématiques
humaines sanitaires environnementales
posées par l'industrie minière tous ces
outils qui comme vous l'expliquez sont
rassurants comme vous le disiez à
l'instant c'est un peu pour bien faire
en fait c'est parce que nous on veut
bien faire en fait déjà c'est pas des
outils pour bien faire c'est pas comme
ça que ça a été créé les moteurs de
création des adhésions et les moteurs de
pardon des initiatives et le moteur
d'adhésion des entreprises c'est à peu
près les mêmes c'est principalement des
enjeux de réputation et ça ça fait
consensus chez tous les auteurs l'enjeu
majeur c'est l'enjeu de réputation c'est
à dire qu'on adhère à ces initiatives à
ses côtes de bonnes conduites assez
guide de ou Recueil de bonnes pratiques
etc on y accède en fait on y accède on y
adhère en tout premier lieu pour des
enjeux réputationnels et je vais faire
le lien avec trois questions que vous
m'avez posées avant certes d'abord des
enjeux pardon par réputationnel de
réputation des enjeux de réputation
d'une part et d'autre part une question
de gestion des risques vous m'avez parlé
tout à l'heure en disant une question de
gestion des risques on est en plein
dedans effectivement c'est à dire que
si une entreprise minière au regard de
l'ensemble des éléments que je vous ai
présenté si une entreprise minière
en fait si on met trop en lumière les
impacts qu'elle a et les risques qu'elle
présente pour la santé humaine comme
c'est fait depuis une vingtaine d'années
et de plus en plus actuellement il y a
un risque énorme c'est pas que un enjeu
de réputation c'est aussi un risque pour
la conduite du projet minier en tant que
tel comme dit désert en 2016 ça peut
coûter très très cher d'avoir soit un
projet minier qui est mis en attente
soit d'avoir des réglementations
contraignantes qui leur tombent dessus
en plus soit au pire du pire en abandon
de projet et on a de multiples exemples
à l'international de projets qui sont
été arrêtés soit à abandonnés parce
qu'effectivement il y avait une pression
de gouvernants des lieux locaux de
population autochtones et locales et pas
seulement en Europe pas seulement en
Europe qui était trop importante en fait
donc effectivement vous avez raison
quand vous parlez ces enjeux de risque
parce qu'en fait on a conçu ces outils
comme une réponse à la gestion des
risques risque de réputation risque
financier indire direct en fait mais en
fait on a internalisé ces risques là et
aujourd'hui c'est considéré comme un
risque majeur c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui les entreprises elles-mêmes
reconnaissent en disant c'est un risque
majeur il faut absolument qu'on s'assure
de notre capacité à
limiter en fait les risques
d'inacceptabilité ce qui parle ce qu'ils
appellent avec des grosses je déteste un
système on déteste ce terme
l'acceptabilité d'un projet mais donc
d'acceptabilité du projet c'est un
risque majeur et donc ils ont la même
approche que ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure c'est des investisseurs c'est la
même gestion du risque que ce qu'on
pourrait voir dans le monde des
investissements c'est Laurent et Merlin
d'ailleurs qui font un très bon
parallèle là dedans en 2021 ou en fait
en fait on ne fait que finalement
internaliser le risque donc le risque en
gros que le projet est des difficultés
que ça ait des implications financières
économiques importantes et donc du coup
en fait pour gérer ça et ben on a mis en
place un certain nombre d'outils et dans
les outils les plus mis en oeuvre et
bien c'est les démarches de
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale parmi lesquels
effectivement les initiatives les codes
de bonne conduite les bonnes pratiques
etc etc donc ça c'est un point
effectivement qui est très important
parce que du coup en fait on aurait
tendance à croire qu'on met
effectivement que historiquement on a
mis en place les bonnes et les
meilleures pratiques dans l'optique et
effectivement de
prendre en charge vraiment à bras le
corps et les situations les
problématiques liées au site minier et
du coup d'améliorer les performances
sociales et environnementales des
entreprises minières c'est pas comme ça
que ça s'est passé c'est pas du tout
comme ça que c'est passé on a créé ces
initiatives et les entreprises adhèrent
aujourd'hui à ses initiatives pour les
enjeux que je viens de vous présenter
précédemment c'est ça l'enjeu majeur un
enjeu de légitimation c'est le but est
de légitimité c'est une formalisation de
la RSE comment c'est votre point de vue
de chercheurs là j'insiste et même ceux
parce qu'en fait vous avez un peu deux
écoles
alors si vous voulez des gens qui sont
un peu pour les initiatives vous pouvez
avoir bridge 2004 Franck 2015 vous avez
villeneuve-étal 2017 peut-être c'est des
noms que certains connaisront moumonetal
2020 freezer il est assez connu Fraser
2021 donc ça c'est des gens qui sont
plutôt pour voilà et ensuite en face
vous avez les gens qui sont plutôt cons
alors je peux vous peut-être qu'il y a
des gens ça valorisent des choses je
peux vous évoquer Setty et milieux Nova
chia vie et Salomon 2016 je peux vous
évoquer vos gueules 2010 tuyau
QI 2010 étal 2019 peut-être qu'il y a
des gens qui ça leur dira des choses
parmi parmi ces sociologues et ces gens
qui travaillent sur la RSE dans tous les
gens que je viens vous dire il y a
effectivement deux écoles les écoles en
fait des gens qui sont plutôt favorables
à la RSE qui constate que ça a mené
quelle science quand une sensibilisation
et qu'il faut poursuivre les efforts
d'un objectif d'amélioration continue
faut pas les décourager et puis il y a
une autre école si je le dis bien sûr
chez bâtiment parce qu'il y a plus
d'écoles deux effectivement les écoles
qui dit sinon il n'y a pas eu d'effets
sur le terrain c'est une catastrophe
voilà c'est une catastrophe il y a pas
d'effets sur le terrain et de fait ça
sert un discours par contre ce qui fait
consensus dans les deux écoles que je
viens de vous montrer ce que tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire en jeu
numéro 1 en jeu de réputation gestion
des risques ça pour le coup ça fait
consensus les gens même qui espèrent
encore si c'est possible que la RSE
puisse aider ou permettre une
amélioration des pratiques dans
l'industrie minière ne nie pas le fait
que la raison pour laquelle on adhère
c'est pas pour résoudre des problèmes de
performance sociale environnementale ne
le lie pas par contre ils estiment que
c'est normal c'est-à-dire qu'on est dans
le cadre d'un projet minier donc en fait
un projet économique
économiqueotechnique et financier à
mener et que du coup c'est donc légitime
en fait que la première chose qu'on
essaye d'assurer c'est la bonne tenue du
projet en tant que tel et la rentabilité
du 10 projets donc voilà ça c'est un
point important et donc effectivement
donc il y a cette RSE et donc pourquoi
je vous en parle parce que du coup
finalement
alors je manquerais de temps
malheureusement pour vous parler plus en
détail probablement de la mine durable
mais par contre ce que je peux vous en
dire c'est que nous on entend beaucoup
beaucoup parler de mine responsables par
contre ça c'est quelque chose dont on
entend parler alors j'insiste sur le
fait que la mine responsable
c'est plutôt un terme qui est plutôt
utilisé par les européens et français
à l'international vous trouverez plutôt
le terme de mine durable et on parle
moins de responsable mining pour mon
mini responsable on peut plus de suce
taïble mining il faut le savoir parce
que du coup c'est vrai qu'il y a un
petit biais un peu européen ce concept
finalement en fait d'après l'étude que
si ce texte a conduite la mine
responsable c'est un synonyme de la mine
durable
mine durable en gros qui finalement donc
comme je l'ai dit n'existe pas non plus
c'est pas nous qu'on le dit c'est une
réalité
et en fait si vous voulez c'est un
synonyme c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est
finalement ça se résume à des principes
généraux des choses qu'on aimerait
atteindre finalement c'est ça qu'il faut
retenir de la mine durable ou de la mine
responsable
même lorsque il y a la mise en place de
bonnes et meilleures pratiques celles-ci
sont généralement des énoncés qui sont
extrêmement imprécis ce sont des
concepts qui sont généralement évasifs
les exigences sont très généralement
faibles même dans les il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'initiatives à l'international
y compris les principes de la scimm je
peux vous pas vous en donner des tonnes
ou tout est très évasif relativement peu
engageant avec une très forte latitude
donc en fait il faut plutôt
conceptualiser la mine durable ou la
mine responsable parce que c'est encore
une fois la minorité est une évaluation
de la mine durable comme plutôt en fait
l'espèce de principe généraux des choses
qu'on aimerait atteindre genre réduire
ces émissions de gaz à effet de serre
consommer moins de ressources lorsque
l'on réalise un traitement minerai oui
c'est des choses un peu général
permettre la participation des
populations locales dans les processus
décisionnels à faire aux activités
minières vous voyez c'est un espèce de
guide de principe généreux mais il y a
rien de concret il y a rien de tangible
et alors encore une fois je peux pas
tout vous décrire ici il y en a 150
pages dans le rapport de système mais il
faut voir à quel point en fait c'est
tous ces mécanismes de RSE sont vraiment
faible faible faible c'est faible c'est
non mis en application il y a pas de
vérification de la conformité il y a pas
de sanction en cas de non conformité
comment mais non c'est pas déjà ça parce
que si ça n'avait pas d'effet ça ne me
poserait pas de problème
problème c'est que toutes ces
initiatives elles ont deux effets elles
ont trois effets majeurs il y en a plein
d'autres mais je vous donne que les
trois premiers 1
et ben ça rentre en conflit majeur avec
le droit
parce que comme le disent hervela et Ayo
en 2022 et ben on crée quelque chose
d'autre c'est air concret de la
régulation volontaire et ça c'est un
énorme souci alors bien d'autres vous
expliquerai comme bis 2016 ou pote 2018
parce que j'ai lu des auteurs avec
lequel je ne partageais absolument pas
les avis mais j'ai souhaité avoir les
avis de tout le monde sur ces sujets et
de fait
ils vont vous dire ah oui non mais
attendez madame Stéphane ne signalez pas
ce cette problématique ne signalez pas
cette problématique de appauvrissement
de la réglementation contraire la
régulation volontaire permet de
compléter elle permet en fait
d'alimenter si vous voulez le droit le
droit contraignant c'est faux c'est faux
c'est faux de chez faux au contraire si
vous en êtes pas convaincu vous pouvez
aller lire Gibson 2000 Campbell et la
Force
10 chercheurs qui ont été cités sur ce
sujet c'est faux les initiatives
volontaires contribuent
l'affaiblissement des réglementations
contraignantes par le simple fait
qu'elle propose quelque chose d'autre et
mieux que cela elle propose quelque
chose qui non seulement est censé avoir
finalement le même effet mais qui pour
celui qui s'engage à y adhérer permet de
ne pas risquer les sanctions financières
peines juridiques et pénale en cas de
non-conformité puisque la très grande
majorité de la RSE ne dispose d'aucun
mécanisme de sanction en cas de
non-conformité quasiment aucun donc ça
veut dire que déjà un ça c'est faux
puisqu'en fait on fait tout pour
l'éviter on fait tout pour éviter la
réglementation au contraire ça affaiblit
et c'est une stratégie de contournement
de la réglementation faut vraiment se
rendre compte de ça donc ça c'est le
premier enjeu je dirais que
effectivement
ça principe au contournement de la
réglementation c'est un outil si vous
voulez sur lequel on se repose pour
contourner la réglementation encore une
fois les auteurs que je vous ai
mentionnés en fait l'explique très bien
alors soit effectivement avec des
exemples en montrant en fait comment
justement du coup on est plus en
capacité finalement de proposer une
réglementation contraignante puisqu'on
va vous dire ah non non il y en a
d'autres et puis après alors vous aurez
beaucoup d'auteurs dans le rapport de
sexe vous les retrouverez aussi qui vont
à même plus loin pour essayer dans cette
thématique là c'est les stratégies mises
en place par le secteur minier pour
contrecarrer les démarches visant à
rendre les initiatives contraignantes en
tout ou partie des initiatives
contraignantes donc ça c'est le premier
moteur donc oui pour répondre à votre
question
je ne dirais pas
je dirais comme vous le proposiez c'est
déjà ça en tous les cas c'est mieux que
rien si un ça ne contribuait pas à soit
mettre en danger le droit soit
l'affaiblir soit le contourner donc si
il y avait pas ça je serai d'accord avec
vous je serai aussi d'accord avec vous
si parallèlement on ne constatait pas
une aggravation des questions sociales
environnementales et humaine alors même
que on n'a jamais vu autant de
initiatives et de démarche qui ont et
qui sont mises en place il y a un
développement exponentiel de toutes ces
initiatives vous constaterez que le
paradoxe est quand même assez frappant
finalement c'est-à-dire qu'on n'a jamais
eu autant d'initiatives proposées pour
faire de la responsabilité sociale des
entreprises on n'a jamais eu autant de
problèmes en particulier en terme de
droit fondamentaux ce qui est d'autant
plus intéressant que
la plupart des initiatives de RSE liées
aux entreprises minières concernent
prioritairement les droits humains c'est
quand même fou donc je ne vous le dirai
pas si effectivement on n'avait pas
parallèlement une aggravation
à ce titre par rapport à ce que vous
disiez sur les plans de transition
lisez vous et d'autres lisez une
publication qui a été faite dans une
revue de droit dont alors le revenu
m'échappe mais les auteurs je les ai
très bien tête c'est fini Stanton fin
fi2n et Stanton c'est une publication
c'est une publication par des juristes
donc c'est un peu parfois c'est un peu
rude à lire par contre c'est passionnant
et ça montre en fait le le développement
vraiment parallèle entre le déploiement
des nouveaux projets de minier de
développement lié à la transition dit à
la transition et le développement des
violations de droits humains toutes
catégories confondus pas seulement les
meurtres et les
autres aberrations qui sont exactions
qui sont commises par les milices armées
c'est vraiment une publication qui est
extrêmement bien été extrêmement
intéressante elle est très récente c'est
2022 et ça a l'air justement sur ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure je ferme
la parenthèse donc effectivement moi je
vous dirais c'est mieux que rien si un
donc on n'avait pas les un enjeux que je
vous ai mentionné donc à la fois le fait
que malheureusement ça contribue à
l'affaiblissement de la réglementation
que en plus ça ne résout pas les
problèmes sur le terrain c'est-à-dire
que ça n'a pas été synonyme de prise en
charge efficace des problématiques
sanitaires environnementales et sociales
et humaine d'ailleurs sur le terrain et
je ne vous le dirai pas non plus si en
fait il y avait pas un autre souci c'est
que de plus en plus d'observateurs et de
chercheurs mettre en évidence et du coup
en fait quand on vous le dit à chaque
fois on vous croit pas mais quand c'est
des sociologues des anthropologues et
des géographes qui vous le disent en
nombre et ben là on est beaucoup plus
rassuré en disant on n'était pas fou en
fait il y avait bien une stratégie c'est
qu'en fait ces outils mindurables ni une
responsable meilleure pratique des
marges de responsabilité sociale des
entreprises ce sont des sous-titres des
outils pardon au service de la
légitimation d'un secteur et donc
beaucoup de chercheurs alors si vous
voulez des noms des bington 2008
bannergies 2018
verveigeonnette dunlope 2021 VOST cobaye
et Andreucci 2022 encore une fois tous
ces auteurs vous les avez dans le
rapport de cystex qui en fait vous
explique comment
toutes ces
mines durable mine responsable bonne
pratique meilleures pratiques en fait
sont des outils des instruments
discursifs qui sont utilisés pour
légitimer l'activité lumière alors bien
il n'y a bien sûr en lien avec ce qu'on
disait sur des enjeux de réputation et
de risque tout à fait on ne revient pas
là dessus mais de légitimation mais
surtout de poursuit des activités
minières et ça fait le lien du coup avec
votre question
je vais vous demander trois bouquins
déjà ça fait longtemps c'est ça qu'on
parle
alors il faut que la prochaine fois on
se mette d'accord par exemple par un
petit aussi
parce que je vais pas vous embêter trois
heures comme ça à chaque fois
si on reste là c'est qu'on aime
les gens ils voulaient en plus
certainement poser des questions en
ligne c'était en fait toutes les
questions vous avez commencé y répondre
indirectement et c'était pas mal trois
bouquins de toutes les façons vous allez
revenir donc trois bouquins
alors
j'ai longtemps réfléchi parce que je lis
beaucoup de livres qui sont pas très
intéressants pour les gens qui veulent
pas lire des trucs des pavés entiers
vous savez sur des questions de droit et
tout c'était pas mais j'ai eu des idées
alors le premier livre auquel j'ai pensé
je l'ai lu il y a longtemps il faut que
je révise c'est le cas du zigane de
George Orwell
c'est un super bouquin fait longtemps
que je l'ai pas lu faudrait que je le
relise du coup
en fait c'est un livre qui a été publié
par George Orwell en 1937 et qui décrit
la situation
de la classe ouvrière au nord de
l'Angleterre dans les zones
Charbonnières et industrielles
c'est en fait c'est alors c'est presque
écrit sous forme de reportage voyez
c'est très descriptif c'est pas un
reportage on s'entend mais enfin c'est
du genre well quand même mais voyez
c'est c'est très descriptif et ça vous
décrit très bien voilà la situation de
la classe ouvrière dans les années 30 le
livre a été publié en 1937 il y a une
très bonne traduction qui a été faite
vraiment qui est très agréable donc
voilà ça c'est un beau bouquin à lire
c'est pour changer un tout petit peu un
de Germinal et de parler de la condition
de travail des gens et de se rappeler
que derrière tu sais il y a des hommes
et des femmes et des femmes et des
hommes qui travaillent dur et qui font
souvent leur maximum même dans des sites
mini actuels pour
produire du métal toujours plus de métal
à déco toujours réduits
le deuxième pour le deuxième j'avais
pensé à un ouvrage un peu plus récent
qui s'appelle paradis sous terre de
Alain de Noé et William sachet qui
s'appelle alors c'est un ouvrage qui est
un peu moins connu que j'ai
personnellement beaucoup pas apprécié ou
comment le Canada est devenu la plaque
tournante de l'industrie minière
mondiale en fait ça vous raconte la
situation
du Canada en termes de régime juridique
fiscaux
assez exceptionnel
avec super sympa donc voilà donc paradis
sous terre publiée en 2012 ça vous
raconte aussi balabour de Toronto il y a
plus de la moitié des entreprises médias
mondiales des sociétés minières
mondiales qui sont basées pour le
troisième
j'avais pensé à un autre livre du coup
si on a beaucoup parlé ce soir la
contamination du monde de François Jarry
j'ai Thomas Leroux qui reviennent en
fait depuis l'ère de l'industrialisation
sur 300 ans de pollution de conflits de
gestion aussi de ces conflits depuis
donc du coup l'ère de
l'industrialisation voilà donc trois
très beaux ouvrages je suis désolée
parce que du coup avec les trois
derniers vous avez vraiment besoin pour
quelqu'un de complètement dépress
vraiment dans ces trois ouvrages il y a
rien de drôle il y a vraiment rien de
drôle mais en tous les cas ces trois
ouvrages magnifiques et des gens qui
écrivent très bien et qui sont surtout
très engagés tous les cinq noms dont je
viens de faire mention c'est tous des
bons il s'avère que c'est 5 messieurs
mais ces cinq personnes qui sont très
angles qui ont été très engagées toute
leur vie et du coup ça se ressent aussi
dans leurs écrits
est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations en plus de celui que
j'ai donné il y a un an
alors j'écoute j'ai pas
réfléchi
personnel pour une fois
si vous vous retrouvez dans ma situation
et que vous avez beaucoup d'attention
qui vous est porté
si vous voulez
rester au plus près de la en fait faut
rester au plus près des réalités
c'est-à-dire en fait quel que soit tout
ce qu'on dit sur vous quel que soit les
marées humaines d'informations et de
communication et toutes les demandes
qu'on vous fait moi en tous les cas je
sais pas si ça peut vous servir
peut-être que ce serait vous sera pas
utile moi ça m'a été très utile c'est de
venir moi mon métier c'est d'être
salarié de cystème c'est des gens quand
on ont besoin de partir sur le terrain
autant que c'est possible de rédiger des
rapports qui n'en finissent pas mais qui
vont aider des gens c'est sûr qui
parlent de la mine responsable des
nodules polymétaniques et des
aberrations des modèles de transition et
c'est ça mon métier avant tout et c'est
pour ça que je me lève le matin et donc
moi en tous les cas je me suis retrouvée
dans une situation où effectivement
j'avais plein plein plein de
sollicitations de plein d'ordre et j'ai
retrouvé mon cap dans la brume grâce à
ce qu'est ce texte à mon travail et aux
gens que je dois absolument aider voilà
merci merci à vous
[Musique]